ravi de vous retrouver sur Public Sénat
dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre le débat sur la
réintégration de la France dans l'OTAN
un retour approuvé par les députés ils
ont voté leur confiance au gouvernement
le 17 mars dernier par 329 voix pour
contre 238 au Sénat il n'y aura pas de
vote malgré les protestations des
sénateurs socialistes ils avaient quitté
l'hémicycle il y a 15 jours au moment de
la déclaration de politique générale
l'opposition dénonce une initiative
susceptible de nuire à l'indépendance de
la France le retour dans l'OTAN ne sera
effectif que les 3 et 4 avril prochains
lors de la célébration des 60 ans de
l'Alliance atlantique à Strasbourg et à
kel en Allemagne mais avant de débuter
ce débat B les sénateurs vont observer à
la demande du groupe communiste une
minute de silence en mémoire d'un
délégué syndical qui s'est donné la mort
après la fermeture de son usine de
porcelaine Philippe desoulière dans la
Vienne qui l'employait il a expliqué son
geste par une pression professionnelle
trop importante tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle bonne séance à
tous je suis saisi d'un rappel au
règlement de madame la Présidente Nicole
borv ONCA présidente du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président de
me donner la la parole mes chers
collègues Philippe viderchauen 56 ans
habitant de mortem délégué syndical CGT
à l'usine de porcelaine desoulière à
chauini dans la Vienne s'est donné la
mort hier il a expliqué son geste par
une trop importante pression
professionnel il avait consacré beaucoup
de son temps de militants de Sal et de
militants syndicales à défendre l'emploi
dans l'entreprise des Soulières celle-ci
à licencié 84 salariés fin décembre je
vous demande d'observer une minute de
silence
je vous
remercie je voulais simplement dire
puisque nous avons la l'information de
cette situation que nous avons une
pensée pour la famille est
proches de cette personne qui avait
gravi tous les échelons professionnels
d'ailleurs
et
ceci ne laisse pas indifférent
l'assemblée nous allons maintenant
aborder une déclaration du gouvernement
suivi d'un débat sur la politique
étrangère de la France la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Bernard couchner
ministre des Affaires étrangères et
européennes vous avez la parole monsieur
le
ministre
merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les
Sénateurs il y a plus de 40 ans le
général de Gaulle a prise une décision
qui a marqué c'est vrai un jalon
important dans notre politique
étrangère aujourd'hui la décision du
Président de la République publque de
parachever le mouvement entamé sous
François mitteran poursuivi sous Jacques
Chirac de rapprochement puis de plein
retour de la France dans la structure
militaire intégrée suscite un
débat comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire ce débat est légitime au sein
d'une démocratie comme la
nôtre mais je vous en prie mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs laissons de côté
les fantasmes et non dit car la sécurité
de la France son indépendance et le rôle
de l'Europe sen
racine depuis 60 ans mais peut-être
encore plus aujourd'hui au cœur de notre
relation avec
l'utant les interrogations légitimes sur
une prétendue perte d'indépendance de
souveraineté ou d'ambition voire sur le
renoncement à une politique étrangère
digne de ce nom
masque les vraies questions sur le sens
le contenu et la portée de notre
indépendance et notre politique
étrangère le président de la République
le 11 mars et le Premier ministre la
semaine dernière à l'Assemblée nationale
ont été très clair à ce propos à ce
propos
permettez-moi de revenir devant vous sur
le sens de notre
décision en prenant toute sa place dans
l'ut temp et en revenant dans son
commandement
la France ne diminue en rien son
indépendance militaire trois principes
fondamentaux continueront de régir notre
participation à
l'alliance d'abord l'indépendance
complète de notre dissuasion
nucléaire deuxièmement la liberté totale
d'appréciation sur la conduite des
opérations et le bien fondé de celle-ci
ce qui signifie le rejet de toute
automaticité dans nos engagements
militaires refus de toute
automaticité et enfin la liberté de
décision en toute circonstances qui
suppose qu'aucune force française ne
soit placée en permanence en temps de
paix sous le commandement de
l'OTAN quoiquon en pense sur le
fond l'exemple récent de l'Espagne
membre important de l'OTAN décidant de
retirer son contingent de la kefor
la force de l'otane au Kosovo est
l'exemple même de la liberté de choix
laissé aux membres de
l'organisation quoi qu'on en pense sur
le
fond on nous a aussi dit revenir dans le
commandement intégré de l'EMP ne
constitue pas un grand changement dans
les faits il serait donc inutile de le
faire bien si au contraire nous pourrons
désormais participer pleinement et en
toute conscience
déb inter nous étions jusque là Absen
qui contesterait qu'il s'agit là d'un
renforcement de notre opposition
d'ailleurs je viens parler des Espagnols
il nous ont félicité gouvernement de
Monsieur
Zapatero et hier en Angleterre nous
avons été également félicités par le
gouvernement de Monsieur Gordon Brown et
si vous avez lu la presse les Russes
dis nous avons bien fait de revenir dans
l' temp nousons enfin un ami
tous nos partenaires européens
d'ailleurs tous se
réjouissent car ils ont bien compris eux
qu'en jouant pleinement notre rôle au
sein de l'OTAN nous pourrons faire
valoir plus efficacement le projet
européen nous n'aurons plus de double
langage essayant de renforcer et nous le
ferons en
permanence la défense européenne nous ne
serons pas accusé de
vouloir au contraire de vouloir donner
moins de sens à notre engagement dans
l'ANT et plus précisément donc nous
pourrons les mains libres nous attacher
à une défense européenne digne de ce nom
dans toutes les
capitales les réactions sont positives
rendez-vous quand vous voulez non
seulement parmi les États qui ont été
les derniers à rejoindre l'Union
européenne et l'OTAN mais aussi par les
pionniers de la la construction
européenne les Italiens les Belges les
Néerlandais les Luxembourgeois et les
Allemands je viens de le dire elles sont
favorables ces réactions chez les
Britanniques avec lesquelles nous avons
lancé il y a 10 ans fort justement le
processus de
saint-malot nos partenaires européens
voient dans notre choix l'occasion d'une
clarification qui rendra plus simple les
rapports entre l'Europe et l'Alliance et
que disent nos alliés américains
il saluent notre décision cela ne vous
surprendra pas mais ils vont plus loin
je vous invite à lire la déclaration du
président
Obama celui-ci affirme dans ce texte
qu'il souhaite dans le même temps que
les capacités de défense de l'Union
européenne se renforc président Obama
nos amis alliés américains aujourd'hui
savent qu'ils ont désormais besoin d'une
Europe forte et
volontaire pour eux désormais il n'y a
plus de contradiction entre
l'appartenance à l'Alliance atlantique
et l'existence d'une vraie défense
européenne et je vous le répète que
disent les Russes sont-ils inquiets
voi-il dans notre décision le
raidissement d'un camp occidental et le
retour d'une logique d'affrontement
non tout au contraire ils sont
convaincus que la présence française
renforcera le poids des Européens dans
les processus de décision et ils y sont
favorables parce qu'il ils savent que
cela va dans le sens d'un renforcement
des relations entre la Russie et
l'alliance que nous appelons de nos
vœux nos partenaires européens ont-ils
exprimé une inquiétude ont-ils crié à la
trahison non plus ils savent bien que
nos positions dans la région ne sont pas
déterminé par notre place à l'intérieur
du commandement intégré de l'OTAN en
d'autres termes ils savent que notre
retour au sein du commandement intégré
n'altère en rien l'indépendance de notre
politique
étrangère la décision dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui est une décision au sein
d'un ensemble et c'est l'ensemble que je
vous demande de considérer sans
précipitation ni
préjugé la France est au petit nombre
qui ont des nations qui ont une
politique
étrangère c'est une évidence pour les
Français mais cela reste une exception
dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui une politique étrangère
c'est une ambition une volonté et des
moyens il revient à la diplomatie de
trouver la bonne alchimie entre les
instruments de puissance classique et ce
de ce qu'on appelle le soft power de
sorte que notre politique étrangère
mette notre notre pays en mesure de
peser sur la scène internationale nous
ne pouvons négliger aucune de ces deux
dimensions nous sommes confrontés à un
monde chaotique et instable nous y
faisons face avec réalisme et
détermination dans le respect de nos
valeurs et de nos intérêts je ne
prendrai ici que trois exemples la
Russie par exemple puisque nous en avons
déjà parlé avec laquelle Russie il est
nécessaire que la France et l'Union
européenne entretiennent une relation
durable
équilibrée respectueuse de part et
d'autre fondée sur notre interdépendance
notamment dans No domaine
énergétique nous entendons le faire sans
complaisance et sans transiger sur les
principes
en évitant les provocations inutiles la
crise géorgienne a montré l'été dernier
que l'Europe lorsqu'elle avait la
volonté politique parvenait à s'exprimer
d'une seule voix et quel qu'était dans
ce cas mais dans ce cas seulement
qu'elle éêre entendue et
respecté c'est l'Europe en effet qui dès
le début du conflit a mesuré le danger
que nous courons à laisser faire qui a
fait Préval le droit et le dialogue sur
la force et qui a su trouver une
solution de paix et les moyens de la
mettre en œuvre sur le
terrain deuxème exemple le Proche et le
Moyen-Orient qui sont notre voisinage
immédiat ce qui s'y joue est essentiel
notamment pour notre propre sécurité
nous y sommes très actifs à titre
national et au sein de l'Union
européenne nous avons restauré avec
Israël une relation de confiance et
d'amitié tout en disant de manière
claire et parfaitement audible au plus
haut niveau qu'il n'y aura pas d'Israël
vivant en paix dans des frontières sûres
et reconnues sans un État palestinien
viable et donc sans un arrêt de la
politique actuelle de
colonisation nous avons avec le Liban
des liens historiques qui ne se sont
jamais distendu même dans les grands
moments de
difficulté nous avons joué avec l'Égypte
un rôle central dans la sortie de crise
à Gaza même si ça n'est pas terminé
hélas et nous continuerons avec nos
partenaires européens à soutenir
l'Autorité palestinienne et le peuple
palestinien nous sommes nous avons
renoué le dialogue avec la Syrie après
l'élection du président Siman au Liban
je vous signale qu'hier la syriie a
nommé son premier ambassadeur au Liban
ce qui est aussi un succès de notre
politique sur un autre dossier essentiel
l'Iran nous avons joué avec le
Royaume-Uni et l'Allemagne un rôle
majeur raliant la Russie la Chine et les
États-Unis à la stratégie de dialogue et
de sanction que nous avons défini et
poursuivi depuis 2003 avec constance
malgré les critiques de toutes
parts et à laquelle le président Obama
vient de donner une impulsion que nous
sal avec son offre de dialogue à
téran nous avons renforcé notre présence
dans le golfe avec notamment
l'installation d'une base militaire à
Abu Dhabi et nous sommes de retour en
Irak et si l'on veut poursuivre l'arc de
crise que j'évoquais à l'instant notre
présence militaire et notre aide civile
ont été encore récemment renforcé en
Afghanistan dans le cadre d'une
stratégie globale à laquelle se ralit
désormais tous nos principaux
partenaires approche d'ensemble puisqu
il n'y a pas de solution militaire à ce
conflit dimension régionale utilité
d'amorcer un dialogue entre afghans
pouvant déboucher sur une réconciliation
nationale 3è exemple les États-Unis avec
lesquels nous avons renoué une relation
forte et confiante fondée sur des
intérêts partagés et des valeurs
communes ce rapprochement
entamé sous la précédente administration
américaine a été é confirmé depuis
l'élection de Monsieur Barack Obama dont
les premières orientations de politique
étrangèr montrent une forte proximité
avec nos propres
dispositions c'est ce pr ce
rapprochement pardon doublé d'une d'un
soutien public du président des
États-Unis à la défense européenne qui a
ouvert la voie au retour de la France au
sein de la structure militaire intégré
de l'Alliance atlantique c'est notre
intérêt comme c'est celui de l'Union
européenne de pouvoir partager le
fardeau de la gestion des crises dans un
esprit de complémentarité et avec le
souci constant de faire vivre nos
valeurs et nos principes sur le terrain
au Kosovo en geéorgie au Tchad en mer
d'Aden partout où grâce à notre action
acharnée nous avons fait flotter le
drapeau européen au service de la paix
et de la
sécurité la politique européenne de
sécurité de défense la peste à
progress poursuivez monsieur le ministre
non mais j'allais le faire monsieur je
reprends mon souffle non non mais c'est
une affaire de diagnostic mais je
comprend c'est bien pourquoi je me
sentais concerné monsieur le Président
bien sûr alors la peste a progressé sur
le terrain mais elle a aussi connu des
avancé considérables sur notre
présidence dans ses outils ses concepts
et ses institutions
je ne citerai que quelquesunes des
nombreuses aventé enregistré par
certains par certains une série de
projets capacitaire robuste flexible
interopérable sont proposés aux
étatsmembres au service d'un nouveau
niveau d'ambition et Monsieur Hervé
Morin pourra vous en dire plus s'il le
souhaite nous en parlerons ne prenez pas
les paris
làdessus un programme d'échange
d'officiers de type Erasmus et le
renforcement du Collège Européen de séc
de défense développeront cette
interopérabilité surtout une culture
commune la création parmi les officiers
de cette culture européenne de défense
est fondamentale à nos yeux enfin une
capacité unique de planification
stratégique des opérations de l'Union
européenne créé avec un secrétariat
général du Conseil et pas encore une
direction
attende ces dernières semaines j'ai
beaucoup entendu les responsables
regretter que l'Union européenne ne
dispose pas d'un état major mais soyons
précis l'Union a un état major depuis
l'an 2000 bah oui ah bon l'Union a un
état major depuis l'an 2000 ce dont il
s'agit c'est la constitution progressive
d'une capacité de planification et de
conduite d'opération à Bruxelles cela
n'a pas encore été fait mais cette
perspective demeure plus encore l'Europe
avance comme cela il faut de la ténacité
de l'obstination il faut quelques années
parfois et nous y
parviendrons mesurez bien que cette
énumération rapide des opérations en
cours et des avancées institutionnelles
trop rapides énumération d'ailleurs
représente comme progrès en manière
d'Europe de la défense oui qui pourrait
contester que l'Europe de la défense a
avancé considérablement avancé qu'elle a
apporté une contribution inestimable à
la paix mais j'ai progrès vous avez
raison il en faudra
d'autres regardez le chemin parcouru
pendant des décennies la défense
européenne était un tabou à saintmalot
elle est devenue un rêve nous nous en
avons fait une réalité et nous
continuerons
ensemble dans la le monde globalisé qui
est le nôtre il ne suffit pas de
proclamer qu'aucune nation même la plus
puissante ne peut régler seule les
problèmes du monde il faut encore en
tirer les justes conclusions dans
l'avenir les États-Unis auront autant
besoin de nous Européens que nous aurons
besoin
d'eux nous ne sommes plus au temps de la
guerre froide et de l'opposition des
blocs nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
plus autant de l'hyperpuissance
américaine qui a marqué les deux
dernières décennies nous sommes en
revanche dans un temps où la libre
alliance des peuples et des démocraties
indépendante mais solidaire contribuera
à la stabilité et à la sécurité du
monde soyons lucides en effet s'il vous
plaît les menaces et les risques ne sont
accru se sont accru et personne aucune
nation aucune nation ne peut
pétendre efficacement protéger ses
citoyens dans un splendide
isolement l'ambition de la France n'est
pas de se résigner à un monde de conflit
et de crise sans faire valoir ses
propres vues l'expérience de la
présidence française de l'Union
européenne nous a conforté dans la
certitude que notre ambition sera
d'autant mieux assumé que nous saurons
la faire partager par
d'autres qui sont aujourd'hui où sont
aujourd'hui nos responsabilités
responsabilité c'est un moton a
peut-être pas assez entendu au cours des
débats de ces dernières
semaines et pourtant c'est bien de cela
qu'il s'agit de notre responsabilité
c'est-à-dire de comprendre que la paix a
un prix dans une vieille nation qui a
tant souffert et au cours de tant de
conflits affirmer que nous souhaitons la
paix et la sécurité pour tous suscite
aisément le consensus
les divergences viennent ensuite quand
il s'agit de tirer toutes les
conclusions de cette
affirmation
l'Europe qui constitue pour l'heure un
îot de
stabilité et qui par rapport aux autres
est encore riche ne peut-être la seule à
négliger sa propre sécurité nous nous
heurtons à des limites qui mettent en
cause notre
crédibilité le monde reste dangereux ne
fermons pas les
yeux ne soyons pas comme les nations
fatigué dont parle toville qui accepte
qu'on les dupe pourvu qu'on les
repose pendant longtemps en effet
l'Europe n'a pas voulu prendre ses
responsabilités sur la scène du monde
notamment en matière de sécurité les
Européens voulait seulement qu'on les
laisse en paix il s'accommodait fort
bien de la protection d'un plus
puissant mais il n'y a pas de diplomatie
s'il n'y a pas de
défense l'Europe s construite à travers
les défis successifs qu'elle a su
relever le premier défi fut celui des
séquelles de la guerre et de la barbarie
nazie la deuxième fut celui du rideau de
fer et des ravages du
communisme le défi pour l'Europe
aujourd'hui c'est d'apprendre à porter
la paix et la sécurité à l'extérieur de
ces frontières ayant su répondre aux
deux défis précédents par une constante
réinvention et par un changement de
dimension le Europe est aujourd'hui
capable avec la même ambition et la même
volonté dans le respect de son histoire
et de ses valeurs de s'attaquer au
nouveaux défis qui se présentent à elle
où nous conduisait le splendide
isolement que certains
préconisent et que personne ne comprend
hors de nos frontières il ne mènerait
pas assurément au résultats que l'on
promet pour ma part dans indépendance
j'entends capacité à faire des choix à
prendre des responsabilités et à peser
sur le cours des choses oui c'est vrai
le geste
gaulien de 66 a donné un éclat
particulier à notre
pays beaucoup de peuples ont vu dans ce
geste un appel un message un
symbole mais ce geste qui s'est figé au
cours des années suivantes risquait de
se transformer en dénis des
réalités et ce et c étaé très
inquiétant autant l'indépendance suscite
l'admiration autant l'oubli des réalité
suscite la méfiance et même
l'inimitié je ne parle pas d'arrogance
d'ailleurs qui serait le contraire même
de l'influence
et qui doit être au cœur de la politique
étrangère le général de Gaulle a pris sa
décision dans l'intérêt de notre
indépendance dans un contexte historique
et stratégique totalement différent du
contexte
d'aujourd'hui de nos jours la décision
de reprendre toute sa place dans
l'alliance préserve entièrement notre
indépendance mais surtout et c'est cela
qui est essentiel mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs elle renforce notre
influence influence dans l'alliance
Europe dans la relation transatlantique
et dans le
monde en somme quel est notre
choix c'est mettre plus de France en
Europe plus d'Europe dans l'Alliance
atlantique et plus de défense dans
l'Union européenne et si vous me
permettez cette allusion c'est cela
aussi avoir une certaine idée de la
France je vous en
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Jocelin droan président de la commission
des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues rien ne peut faire qu'une
alliance demeure telle quelle quand on
changeait les conditions dans lesquelles
on l'avait
dans ce cas-là il faut adapter aux
données nouvelles la loi le traité
l'alliance si on ne le fait pas alors
les textes sont vidés de leur substance
et ce ne sont plus le cas échéant que de
20 papiers d'archive à moins que ne se
produise une rupture brutale entre les
formes desésèes et les vivantes réalités
ce propos du général de Gaulle en 1966
est parfaitement transposable quand il
s'agit de nos relations avec l' même
s'il est vrai que la conjoncture de
1996 n'avait rien à voir avec celle de
1966 ni celle de 2009 avec celle de
1996 tout a changé depuis le temp le
général de Gaulle avait retiré nos
troupes du commandement intégré de
l'OTAN la nature des défis auxquels les
membres de l'Alliance doivent faire face
les zones de conflit potentiels
l'apparition de nouveaux facteurs de
déstabilisation dans le monde ce sont
ces raison qui avait conduit la France à
se rapprocher de l'OTAN 1996 et
d'effectuer la plus grande partie du
chemin en réintégrant la plupart des
comités militaires de
l'organisation il n'entre nullement dans
mon esprit de minimiser la décision du
Président de la République de réintégrer
le comité des plans de Défense de l'OTAN
en soulignant qu'il s'agirait simplement
d'une évolution pas d'avantage ne
doit-on exagérer la portée symbolique de
l'événement comme l'a dit le 11 mars
dernier le président de la République
dans le monde des puissances relatives
aucun État ne peut imposer seul son
point de vue dès lors la coopération et
la solidarité sont les fondements de
l'action cette coopération et cette
solidarité sont au cœur de notre
diplomatie elle trouent l'une de leurs
traductions privilégié dans notre
participation active aux grandes
organisations qui structurent la vie
internationale c'est le cas bien entendu
dans l'Organisation des Nations Unies
qui reste pour la France l'élément C des
relations internationales et de la
sécurité collective et au sein de
laquelle nous voulons pleinement assumer
nos responsabilités de membres permanent
du Conseil de sécurité c'est le cas à
l'Union européenne qui a tant mobilisé
notre énergie ces derniers mois avec la
conclusion du traité de Lisbonne et
notre présidence le semestre dernier
c'est le cas d'autres organisations et
parmi elles dans le domaine de la
défense de l'Alliance atlantique dont
nous sommes membres depuis 60 ans et à
travers laquelle nous réalisons depuis
15 ans une large part de nos engagements
militaires en faveur du rétablissement
et du maintien de la paix sous mandat
des Nations Unies s'impliquer dans les
organisations international ne serait
bien évidemment constituer une fin en
soi ce n'est qu'un moyen au service
d'une politique destinée à garantir nos
intérêts nationaux et à défendre les
notre pays est attaché c'est bien cette
démarche qui a suivi le président de la
République à l'égard de l'OTAN la
décision prise par le chef de l'État
dans le cadre de responsabilité qui
relève naturellement de l'exécutif
s'appuie sur l'analyse stratégique
extrêmement approfondie menée dans le
cadre du Livre blanc sur la défense de
la sécurité nationale l'articulation de
nos engagements dans la défense
européenne et dans l'Alliance atlantique
était l'une des questions majeur que la
Commission du Livre Blanc était chargée
de traiter c'est un point sur lequel
notre commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense a été d'autant plus
attentive au cours de ces derniers mois
que dans un rapport d'information
consigné par des sénateurs de la
majorité de l'opposition I et publié dès
juillet 2007 elle avait dressé un état
des lieux d'une autant profondément
transformé depuis la fin de la guerre
froide et qu'elle avait appelé à définir
plus clairement notre position dès lors
que nous étions dans les faits l'un des
principaux acteurs de l'organisation la
décision du Président de la République
est cohérente car elle s'insère dans la
stratégie d'ensemble définie par le
livre blanc pour mettre en adéquation
nos moyens notre cadre d'action au plan
international et les nécessités de notre
défense et de notre sécurité elle est
cohérente car elle considère l'intérêt
de notre pleine participation aux
organes de direction et au postes de
responsabilité de l'OTAN à l'ône d'une
réalité incontestable à savoir notre
contribution constante à toutes les
opérations de l'Alliance depuis 15 ans à
cet égard le Premier ministre a évoqué
la semaine dernière un ajustement de
notre position je crois en effet que
s'il fallait véritablement rechercher un
bouleversement c'est pas dans la
politique française d'aujourd'hui qu'on
la trouverait mais je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure plutôt dans les les mutations
intervenues au sein de l'OTAN avant la
fin de la guerre froide cela a été
abondamment souligné ces derniers mois
il n'y a plus grand-chose de commun
entre l'OTAN d'avantière organisé face à
une menace unique identifiée et
permanente et celle qui s'est investi
depuis le conflit des Balcans dans les
missions de gestion de crise force est
également de constater que la France
sous les gouvernements successif a
pleinement encouragé ce mouvement c'est
d'ailleurs sous une autre majorité qu
été pris les décisions majeures
d'intervenir au Kosovo et en Afghanistan
qui sont à la base de nos deux
engagements principaux dans les
opérations de
l'OTAN dès
lors dès lors la question d'un
renforcement de notre présence dans les
structures internes de l'alliance se
posait de manière légitime
l'indépendance de notre politique
étrangère et notre politique de défense
ne peut aucunement s'en trouver affecté
nos obligations vis-à-vis du Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord ne sont en rien
modifié elles demeure ce qu'elles n'ont
jamais cessé d'être depuis 60 ans
c'est-à-dire qu'ell n'implique aucune
automaticité et laisse à la France comme
aux autres pays membres sa totale
liberté d'appréciation dans une
organisation qui fonctionne sur la base
du consensus à tous les stades de la
décision au demeurant l'action menée par
la France sur la scène internationale et
la capacité d'initiative dont elle a
fait preuve sur tous les grands dossiers
ne laisse aucun doute sur la volonté du
Président de la République et du
gouvernement de continuer à faire
entendre la voix de notre pays à faire
voloir nos positions et à jouer notre
rôle propre à l'opposé de tout
alignement ou d'effacement dans un bloc
l'ambition européenne doit bien entendu
demeurer l'un des axes majeurs de notre
politique extérieure et notre politique
de défense la politique européenne de
sécurité de défense a prisor elle est
plus que jamais nécessaire dans le
contexte de crise économique et
financière qui doit nous inciter à
regrouper nos efforts et à mutualiser
nos moyens notons cependant que les plus
hautes autorités américaines se sont
prononcées en sa faveur le président
Bush au sommet de Bucharest le président
vice-président Biden à
Munich sans doute ne s'est-elle pas
développé aussi rapidement cette
politique que nous pouvions souhaiter il
reste beaucoup à faire pour rapocher les
politiques d'équipement consolider
l'industrie européenne de défense et
renforcer la capacité de l'Union
européenne à mettre sur pied et à
diriger des opérations mes chers
collègues nous avons entendu ces
derniers temps beaucoup de professions
de foi sur la défense européenne y
compris de la part de ceux qui avait
activement uvré au rejet du traité
constitutionnel en 2005 avant de
s'opposer au traité de
Lisbonne
mais l'Europe de la défense ne se
décrète pas depuis Paris pas mais
l'Europe ne la fait défense se décrète
pas depuis Paris pas plus qu'elle ne
peut se proclamer du haut d'une tribune
elle se construit avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires et de ce point de vue nous
pouvons à mon sens avoir deux certitudes
la première c'est que la détermination
de la France à développer la PESD reste
toujours aussi forte le président de la
République l'a redit le 11 mars
construire l'Europe de la défense et de
la sécurité c'est une priorité absolue
les progrès engrangés durant la
présidence française constituent un
jalon important sur la voie de nouvelles
avancées la seconde certitude c'est que
si nous Pr édifier l'Europe de la
défense indépendamment de l'OTAN ou à
forcerie contre elle nous irons
inévitablement à l'échec 20 de nos
partenaires européens et parmi eux les
plus importants sont également membres
de l'OTAN sans restriction aucune quant
à leur degré de participation aux
structures de décision et de
commandement c'est pourquoi il me paraît
tout à fait cohérent si l'on veut donner
de vraies perspective à l'Europe de la
défense d'insister comme le fait le
président de la République sur la
complémentarité entre celle-ci et l'OTAN
ce n'est pas en déclarant la pleine
participation à l'OTAN incompatible avec
l'Europe de la défense que nous
fédérerons nos partenaires sur le projet
européen alors même qu'un nombre
croissant de ceux-ci manifeste un
intérêt pour sa mise en œuvre nous avons
une chance sur deux mes chers collègues
de réaliser une politique européenne de
sécurité de la défense en étant à
l'intérieur de l'OTAN nous avons aucune
chance de le faire en restant en dehors
car les pays de l'Europe de l'Est par
exemple ne voudront pas trop
la sécurité problématique d'une
politique européenne contre la sécurité
que leur donne l'Alliance atlantique
c'est un fait pour conclure
j'effectuerai deux
observations la première monsie le
Président je peux continuer allez-y
monsieur s'il vous plaît la première est
que comme je l'ai déjà souligné la
modification de notre position dans les
structures de l'OTAN ne peut-être
considéré comme un objectif en soi cert
nous tirons les conclusions de notre
implication croissante dans les
opérations que nous souhaitons et nous
souhaitons avoir la place qui nous
revient dans les différents circuits de
décision mais il s'agira surtout de
prendre toute notre part à la définition
du rôle des missions et du
fonctionnement d'une organisation qui
doit se réformer et s'adapter à un monde
en changement très rapide les questions
sont nombreuses la stratégie en
Afghanistan les relations avec la Russie
la révision du concept stratégique le
rééquilibrage des responsabilités entre
européens et américains la
rationalisation des structures c'est
pourquoi je me félicite que la France
revendique une implication plus forte
dans la transformation de l'Alliance et
je souhaite bien entendu que les moyens
lui en soient donnés dans le cadre de la
nouvelle répartition des grands
commandements ma seconde observation et
que notre capacité à peser sur le cours
des affaires internationales tiendra
moins à notre statut dans une
organisation à notre présence ou à notre
absence dans tel ou tel comité ou
étatmajor qu'à notre propre volonté de
suivre une stratégie cohérente et de
nous donner les moyens de la mettre en
œuvre il n'y a dans le Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord aucune disposition qui
nous contraigne d'aligner notre
politique sur celle de l'un de nos
alliés fut-il le plus puissant d'entre
eux si tel n'est pas notre intérêt
aucune disposition qui nous oblige à
conduire une opération ou une expédition
que nous désapprouverions aucune
consigne qui puisse forcer sur le
terrain une unité française à exécuter
des ordres contraires à la volonté de
nos état-majors le rôle joué par la
France dans le le conflit russo-géorgien
l'opposition au modalité de
l'élargissement manifesté au sommet de
Bucarest témoigne de la volonté de notre
pays d'agir de manière indépendante et
conforme à notre vision du monde la
véritable garantie de notre indépendance
mes chers collègues et de notre
influence dans le domaine international
réside en réalité dans la capacité que
nous aurons de redresser notre économie
et nos finances publiques de maintenir
l'unité de notre pays de marquer notre
volonté de faire face aux difficultés
que nous rencontrons et de triompher des
obstacles sur notre route c'est de nous
et de nous seuls et de notre
détermination que dépendra notre
sécurité et notre défense ni l'OTAN ni
l'Europe ne pourront rien pour nous si
nous sommes une nation démissionnaire ni
l'Europe ni l'OTAN ne pourront jamais
nous forcer à nous plier des politiques
auxquelles nous ne consentirions pas
parce que nous serions plus un peuple
libre merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant au
président ubert Enel président de la
commission des affaires européennes qui
va d'ailleurs s'exprimer sur le temps de
son groupe vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président merci Monsieur président
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues la
question de la place de la France dans
l'Autan doit être abordé en fonction du
rôle que joue notre pays dans un monde
qui a fondamentalement changé depuis les
années anné 60 et le rôle de la France
aujourd'hui est avant tout un rôle
européen certes notre horizon ne se
réduit pas à l'Europe
mais le premier cercle de notre identité
et de notre action désormais la France
se définit d'abord comme un État membre
de l'Union européenne or qu'on me
pardonne cette évidence nous
construisons l'Europe avec nos 26
partenaires certes mais tels qu'ils sont
et sur les questions de défense beaucoup
ont une vision différente de la nôtre
une participation plus complète aux
structures de l'OTAN ne va pas
bouleverser la donne de notre action
extérieure de notre défense elle va tout
simplement parachever un rapprochement
engagé depuis le début des années 90 qui
a fait de la France le 4e contributeur
de
l'Alliance si cette participation plus
complète n'est donc pas dans les faits
un changement majeur elle est un symbole
politique très important qui va modifier
l'image de la France notre pays sera
vraissemblablement perçu comme plus
proche des États-Unis il est peut-être
possible dans que dans certaines parties
du monde son image se trouve quelque peu
altéré au moins dans un premier temps
mais si l'on admet que la construction
européenne est bien au centre de notre
action extérieure c'est avant tout sous
cet angle européen qu'il faut apprécier
ce symbole politique nous le savons tous
Lorsque la France parle de défense
européenne lorsqu'elle parle d'Europe
puissance elle est toujours soupçonné de
jouer l'Europe contre l'OTAN et tant que
ce soupçon n'aura pas disparu
reconnaissons-le nous ne parviendrons
pas à convaincre nos partenaires d'aller
vraiment vers une identité européenne de
défense il faut donc surmonter ce
blocage si nous voulons donner toutes
ses chances à l'Europe de la défense
naturellement notre investissement accru
dans l'ut temp ne va pas comme par
miracle désarmer toutes les préventions
et lever tous les obstacles mais nous
faisons sauter un verrou et nous privons
nos partenaires d'alibi or nous avons de
sérieux arguments pour justifier la
construction d'un pilier européen de
l'Alliance personne ne peut dire que
l'Union n'a pas d'intérêt propre et de
responsabilité
spécifique personne ne peut dire que les
États-Unis seront toujours là pour
assurer la stabilité au voisinage de
l'Europe il y aura très
vraisemblablement des situations où les
États-Unis jugeront que leurs intérêts
ne sont pas suffisamment en jeu pour
intervenir alors que les Européens
jugeront quant à eux qu'il est
nécessaire d'agir et s'ils n'ont pas les
Européens les moyens d'une action
autonome qui soit organis cohérente ils
n'agiront pas ou ils agiront mal
l'Europe a besoin d'une capacité
d'action autonome et cette capacité elle
ne pourra la construire que sous une
forme qui soit compatible avec
l'Alliance il y a un moment où il faut
cesser de tourner autour du pot comme on
dit familièrement l'Europe de la défense
ne peut se construire que sur la base
d'un accord
franco-anglais nous avons vu quelle
impulsion a donné il y a 10 ans l'accord
de
SaintMalo sur cette base en partant de
presque rien nous avons fait des progrès
qui dans l'absolu c'est vrai reste
encore loin de ce qui serait nécessaire
mais qui ont été extrêmement rapide nous
ne pourrons pas aller beaucoup plus loin
sans lever l'hypothèque que constitue
nos rapports avec l'autant bien entendu
je l'ai dit notre retour dans l' temp ne
garantira pas de façon absolue le
progrès de l'Europe de la défense mais
il le rendra possible et le jeu en vaut
la chandelle s'il y a un domaine où l'on
peut parler du coût de la non Europe
c'est bien celui de la défense bien
entendu l'effort de défense des pays
européen et sans commune mesure avec
celui des États-Unis il représente en
moyenne moins de
1,7% du PIB contre 4,5 % pour les
États-Unis le total des dépenses des
pays membr représente à peu près 40 %
des dépenses des États-Unis les
Européens n'en dépensent pas pas moins
ensemble mais quand même plus de 200
milliards d'euros pour leur défense ce
n'est pas rien surtout il faut mettre ce
montant en rapport avec les objectifs
que peut raisonnablement se fixer
l'Union il ne s'agit pas de construire
une super puissance mais d'avoir une
capacité d'action autonome pour remplir
les missions que fixent les traités
européen il est frappant de constater
que les effectifs cumulés des armées des
pays membres de l'Union dépassent ceux
de l'armée
américaine
2290000 soldats pour l'Europe
275000 pour les États-Unis les moyens
humains en Europe sont là pour peu que
nous apprenions à mieux agir ensemble ce
qui fait la différence c'est
l'investissement c'est-à-dire les
dépenses d'équipement et de Recherche
Développement l'investissement par
soldat
est 5 fois supérieur à l'investissement
par soldat
européens ce qui explique un écart aussi
considérable c'est en partie le fait que
les Européens ne sont pas prêts à faire
les mêmes efforts que les européens en
matière de défense certes mais c'est
aussi le fait que les Européens ont été
jusqu'à présent incapa je dis bien
incapable de mutualiser ce type de
dépense d'investissement alors qu'elle
dépasse les les possibilités des
États-membres pris séparément mais si
l'on admet d'une part que nous avons
besoin d'une Europe de la défense et
d'autre part que cette Europe de la
défense ne pourra se construire qu'en
étant compatible avec l'Alliance et
complémentaire de celle-ci alors il faut
admettre la conséquence il n'est pas
dans l'intérêt de l'Europe que nous
maintenions
d'ambigué sur notre place au sein de
l'OTAN aujourd'hui elle est un frein
plus qu'un atout pour Europe de la
défense je voudrais rappeler en
conclusion monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres la formule
d'Edgar fort il n'y a pas de politique
sans risque mais il y a des politiques
sans chance en modifiant notre oppition
au sein de l'an nous donnons de
meilleures chance à l'Europe de la
défense et c'est à mon avis le critère
essentiel qui doit nous guider dans ce
débat merci monsieur le
Président dans la suite notre débat la
parole est aux orateurs des groupes et
je la parole à Monsieur Louis Mermaz
pour le groupe
socialiste pour 15 minutes vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président monsieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues temp l'exposé de notre
rapporteur monsieur Jocelin deorang je
pensais à deux verres de
Budel
réversibilité ange plein de gaieté
connaissez-vous l'angoisse ou si vous
préférez ange plein de santé
connaissez-vous les fièvre car en
écoutant votre démonstration j'avais
l'impression que tous les arguments
pouvaient se se renverser d'où une
certaine fragilité permettez-moi de vous
le dire voici donc le Sénat engagé dans
un débat que je caractériserai de débat
fantôme sur le retour de la France dans
le commandement intégré de l'otane plus
d'une semaine après l'Assemblée
nationale et alors que le Président de
la République a déjà notifié
officiellement sa décision au Secrétaire
général de
l'Organisation d'ailleurs nous avions
connu quelque chose de semblable en
matière d'audiovisuel puisque la
publicité avait été décrétée la
suppression de la publicité décrétée sur
leschelle publique avant que le par
Parlement est fini d'en
délibérer au moment mes chers collègues
où l'attention des Français est tournée
vers d'autres sujets l'aggravation de la
crise l'approfondissement des inégalités
derrière le bouclier fiscal en passe de
devenir le symbole de toute une
politique la montée du chômage et nous
attendons avec angoisse les chiffres qui
vont tomber officiellement demain monté
de la protestation sociale voici donc un
débat qui se déroule dans dans une
atmosphère feutrée asceptisé puisqu'il
n'y aura pas de vote loin du regard des
médias déphasé par rapport à
l'actualité le gouvernement en engageant
la semaine dernière sa responsabilité
devant l'Assemblée nationale sur
l'ensemble de sa politique étrangère
voulait en fait interdire à sa
majorité de se prononcer sur le retour
de la France dans le commandement
intégré de l'otane il savait
parfaitement qu'il éviterait ainsi toute
contrariété au président de la
République il savait que les députés de
la majorité ne prendraient pas le risque
de s'opposer au président chef de l'UMP
qui tient la clé des prochaines
investitures législatives et qui
supervise le découpage en cours des
circonscriptions
électorales
ainsi ainsi en moins de 10 jours en
procédant à
l'étouffé avez-vous brisé le consensus
sur la défense et la diplomatie qui
existait dans notre pays depuis des
décennies et que les présidents
successifs avaient
respecté le débat de mardi dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale malgré la
mobilisation forte de l'opposition est
resté somme tout académique puisque les
enjeux étaient faits certains se seront
cependant souvenus de l'affrontement de
haute tenue au printemps
1966 entre le Premier ministre George
Pompidou et François mitteran là aussi
le général de l'avait décidé seul et mis
le Parlement devant le fait accompli
cependant même si la méthode adoptée
alors était éminemment contestable
comparaison n'est pas raison de Gaul
s'était efforcé en effet pendant 8 ans
d'infléchir les positions américaines
avant du fait du silence obstiné de
notre allié d'en tirer les conséquences
sans bien sûr sortir de l'Alliance
atlantique qui assurait à l'Europe de
l'Ouest une protection indispensable au
temps de la guerre froide François
miteran n'avait pas manqué de faire
observer combien il aurait été illusoire
en effet de croire qu'on pu rompre avec
une telle alliance la France depuis a
poursuivi sa route solidaire de ses
alliés mais se refusant à tout
alignement c'est avec cette tradition
que le président actuel prend le risque
de rompre il l'a fait dès l'annonce à
Bucharest en avril 2008 du retour de la
France dans le commandement intégré de
l'otane à la fin de la présidence Bush
sans se poser la question du contexte
international c'est-à-dire une époque où
la croisade menée contre le mal au
Moyen-Orient avait abouti à une série de
désastres en Iran où l'annonce de
l'installation d'un bouclier antimissile
aux frontières de la Russie risquait de
faire peser des menaces graves sur la
paix le président français a développé
dernièrement ses intentions au cours
d'un colloque organisé à l'école
militaire par la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique devant un
arétopage héroclite composé de
militaires et de personnalités diverses
transformé soudain en une sorte de
chambre des
Corporation tout cela alors que personne
ne demandait rien à notre pays a
commencer les États-Unis les raisons
invoquées pour expliquer cette
initiative étrange sont multiples de
circonstances nous aurions ainsi
davantage d'influence sur les États-Unis
ça ferait bon effet sur nos partenaires
européens qui préfèrent l'otane
existante un projet européen certes
encore évanescant de défense le
président Shirak après cette aventurée
avait dû renoncer à une démarche
semblable faute d'avoir obtenu des
Américains le minimum d'assurance tel
que l'accession de notre pays au
commandement des forces militaires en
Méditerranée ce qui aurait été autrement
substantiel que les commandements non
opérationnels de norfol ou de Lisbonne
qu'on nous fait
miroiter mais l'accord de saintmalot
dont le président de la commission de la
défense des Affaires étrangères vient de
nous entretenir a précisément été conclu
entre la France et la Grande-Bretagne au
lendemain de ce refus français
d'intégrer plus complètement
l'otane comme quoi lorsque l'on sait
dire non cela peut avoir des effets très
bénéfiques sur la défense
européenne j'ai été stupéfait pour ma
part et je pense que vous partagerez cet
étonnement voir cette indignation
d'entendre le Premier ministre parler à
l'Assemblée nationale de la faiblesse de
la proposition de Jacques Chirac à cette
époque qui souhaitait justement que la
France prenne le commandement
opérationnel de Naple ce qui auraient
conduit un officier français je cite le
Premier ministre à commander des forces
américaines alors o où en sommes-nous
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette alliance
où nous ne pouvons pas prétendre à
égalité parfois commandé à d'autes
puissance ce qui aujourd'hui est
proprement
ahurissant c'est qu'on ne voit pas ce
que la France a obtenu ou pourrait
obtenir le président de la République se
jette dans une aventure dont il n'a
exploré ni les tenants ni les
aboutissants sans poser de préalable ni
recevoir de garantie il décide seul de
signer un chèque en blanc que personne
ne lui demandait acceptant l'alignement
et la banalisation de la politique
française pendant ce temps la présidence
française de l'Union européenne que
certains ont célébré avec enflure n'a
pas fait avancer d'un yota le défense de
la le dossier de la défense européenne
même si deux ou trois plans allambiqués
ont été évoqués mais rien de nouveau sur
l'état major européen qui reste une
académie rien sur l'élaboration des
prémisses d'une stratégie commune rien
sur l'Agence européenne de défense ou
encore sur la création d'une force
d'intervention rapide de 50 ou 60000
hommes on ne voit pas maintenant que
l'ensemble des pays alliés va se
retrouver dans des structures totalement
intégrées pourquoi nos partenaires
européens soudain accepterait de bâtir
parallèlement une défense européenne à
laquelle les États-Unis ont jusqu'à leur
opposé une sorte de véau et ne
considérerait-il pas que cela ferait
double emploi je poserai trois questions
avant de conclure la guerre s'éternise
en Afghanistan où une issue militaire au
conflit apparaît de plus en plus
aléatoire le nouveau président américain
semble envisager un changement de
politique pour répondre aux exigences
économiques et sociales des populations
ce qui permettrait de s'orienter
progressivement ver un retrait c'est la
thèse que nous avons toujours défendu
mais en attendant mais en attendant
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
vous apprêtez-vous dans le cadre de
l'otane à remettre aux États-Unis le
commandement de la totalité des troupes
françaises engagé en Afghanistan après
modification de leur affectation je vous
pose la question de toute façon elle est
posée même s'il n'y a pas de réponse
aujourd'hui deè question avons-nous
l'assurance désormais que le président
et le gouvernement maintiendront en état
la force de dissuasion nucléaire
française indissociable de notre
souveraineté et conserveront la maîtrise
totale de son emploi gage d'indépendance
et de sécurité dans un monde incertain
je pose cette question même s'il n'est
pas envisagé pour le moment que nous
siégions dans le groupe des plans
nucléaires 3è question alors que l'OTAN
dominé par les États-Unis supervise le
commerce des armes quelle place
conserverons nos propres industries
d'armement est-il raisonnable de nous
aligner alors que nous ignorons tous des
intentions américaines alors que nous ne
sommes évidemment rien associés à
l'élaboration de la politique
internationale des États-Unis est-il
raisonnable de nous intégrer ainsi j'ai
entendu parler que nous partagerions une
même culture militaire que les
États-Unis mais si cette culture devait
consister à commencer l'engagement de
toute opération par des bombardements
mass et indistinct je pense pas que ce
soit là la tradition des militaires
français une nouvelle èir pourrait
peut-être s'ouvrir avec la présidence
Obama mais quand savons-nous encore le
gouvernement le président parle
d'influencer cette politique comme si
nous n'allions pas davantage au
contraire conforter le rôle prépondérant
de l'administration américaine dans
l'alliance
ignorons-nous au demeurant que les
États-Unis se réservent toujours
d'intervenir quand et où bon leur semble
en dehors des structures de l'Alliance
atlantique sans en référer forcément au
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU en fait
vous ne vous posez pas vraiment la seule
question qui vaille l'otane aujourd'hui
pour quoi faire pourquoi faire vis-à-vis
du Moyen et du Proche Orient vis-à-vis
de la Russie et des anciennes
républiques soviétiques demain
éventuellement en nazie puis puisqu'on
parle de l'adhésion de l'Australie et de
la Corée du Sud oui quelles alliances
jusqu'où avec qui contre qui s'agit-il
de l'alliance de toutes les puissances
occidentales face au reste du monde
s'agit-il de l'émergence d'un monde
bipolaire d'un genre nouveau l'Occident
face à tous les autres mais enfin
tenez-vous pour négligeable le rôle
particulier de la France dans l'Union
européenne et dans le monde héritage
d'une longue histoire c'est cet héritage
et cette trad qu' convient de préserver
les États-Unis d'Amérique avec
lesquelles nous partageons oui tant de
valeurs et envers lesquelles nous avons
deux fois été redevable de notre liberté
le SAV encore faut-il que nous nous
croyons nous-même à cet héritage et que
nous le défendions on est enfin en droit
de
s'interroger sur la vision que vous avez
du statut et du rôle de la France et de
sa dimension
universelle au contraire vous
abandonnant à une politique de
renoncement d'abdication et
d'apaissement vous tournez le dos à
cette tradition soyons alliés avec les
États-Unis oui aligné non conservons
notre crédit auprès des peuples qui
refusent les dangers de la
bipolarisation et reprenons un
lasseblement la construction d'une
Europe solidaire mais jamais
vassale un dernier mot vous n'avez de
cesse messieurs du
gouvernement de saluer le Sénat du terme
pompeux de Haute Assemblée alors
pourquoi ce débat décalé sur une
question essentielle ce refus d'accepter
un vote ici pourquoi l'envoi de cette
lettre au secrétaire général de l'otane
l'informant de la décision de
réintégration de la France sans avoir la
desscence d'attendre ce débat serait-ce
parce que le Président de la République
ne dispose pas au Sénat des mêmes moyens
de contraintes sur sa majorité qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale ou parce que cette
majorité est plus courte ou encore parce
qu'il craindrait que des voix
dissonantes se manifestent en son sein à
l'encontre de la parole
officielle sinon l'article 49 de la
Constitution doublé par l'article 50- 1
de la révision aurait parfaitement
permis de demander l'approbation du
Sénat il aurait été intéressant de
connaître en comparaison l'opinion d'une
assemblée qu'on aurait pas mené à la
hussarde bien naïf mes chers collègues
ceux qui ont cru ou fin de croire au
librage des pouvoirs à travers la
prétendue révision
constitutionnelle n'êtes-vous pas sur le
point monsieur le Président du Sénat
monsieur le Président de la Haute
Assemblée de ressembler à ces
gouverneurs de province qui autant de
l'absolutisme n'avait selon la parole de
Saint-Simon conservé pour tout pouvoir
qu'un air de trompette et de
violon
merci mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Yve Pozo di Borgo
pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la parole mon cher
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues
en annonçant la réintégration de la
France au sein de l'allance Atlantique
le président de la République a pris une
décision importante sur le plan
symbolique mais qui en réalité marque
l'aboutissement d'un processus de
rapprochement débuté depuis les années
90 depuis la fin de la guerre froide la
France qu'il faut le rappeler n'a jamais
cessé d'être membre de l'alliance c'est
progressivement approcher des structures
de l'OTAN elle est ça a déjà été dit
mais je suis pour la pédagogie de
répétition elle est le 4e contributeur
financier de cette organisation et elle
a participé à toutes les opérations de
l'Alliance en ex yugosavie comme en
Afghanistan 5000 de nos soldats sont
dépoyés dans le cadre de ces opérations
le débat ne porte que sur le
renforcement de la présence de nos
officiers au sein des structures et
organes de commandement de l'Alliance
pour che is nous saisions dans 36
comités sur 38 et il est question d'être
présent demain que dans le
37e cette décision marque donc un moins
une rupture que l'aboutissement d'un
processus d'ailleurs poursuivi par tous
les gouvernements successifs de droite
comme de gauche elle en demeure pas
moins importante car elle devait
permettre à la France de prendre toute
sa place dans les réflexions actuelles
sur la rénovation de l'Alliance et de
son concept stratégique la décision du
président Sarko
rejoint les fondamentaux de la doctrine
défense de la famille centriste inscrite
dans le mar dans un discours de Jean
Lecué à Camp le 12 mars 66 et qui depuis
n'a jamais varié elle consiste à
affirmer que la défense de l'Europe ne
peut être que bâti sur deux piliers le
pilier Atlantique et le pilier européen
et si certains dans la famille politique
centriste l'ont oublié il aurait mieux
de relire ces textes avec attention vous
avez compris que je m'adresse ici à
celui qui n'a pas le monopole du Centre
François
Baayou depuis la fin de la guerre froide
le contexte géopolitique a radicalement
changé nous devons constater que malgré
l'élaboration d'un nouveau concept
stratégique le rôle de l'OTAN demeure
mal encore mal défini mon cher collègue
à l'image de l'Union européenne
l'organisation s'est élargie à de
nouveau pays mais sans que l'on sache
réellement où doivent s'arrêter ses
frontières faut-il aller jusqu'à
l'Ukraine la Georgie ou encore les pays
d'Asie centrale voire l'Australie et le
Japon personne n'a jusqu'ici réellement
répondu à ces
questions de même avec la disparition de
la menace soviétique la vocation de
l'Alliance n'apparaît plus aussi
évidente comment éviter que cette
organisation soit perçu comme une
alliance de l'Occident qui serait
dirigée contre la Russie ou le monde
musulman ou peut-être plus tard contre
la Chine enfin se pose aussi la question
de la réforme des structures de cette
organisation dont il faut bien dire
qu'elle entretient une bureaucratie
encore
pétorique en clarifiant sa position
vis-à-vis d'alliance cela devrait
permettre à notre pays de prendre toute
sa place dans l'élaboration du nouveau
concept stratégique de l'Alliance
atlantique c'est-à-dire dans la
définition de son futur périmètre de
l'avenir de son rôle et de son mode de
fonctionnement surtout pour nous
centristes la réintégration pleine et
entière de la France dans les structures
militaires de l'Otan devrait favoriser
le renforcement de la politique
européenne de sécurité de défense j'en
veux pour preuve ça déjà été dit par
notre collègue Enel et par le ministre
Affaires étrangères les réactions très
positif de nos partenaires européens à
l'annonce de la décision du Président de
la République à l'image de la chancelère
Angela Merkel faut-il rappeler que 21
des 27 membres faut-il rappeler que 21
des 27 étant membres de l'Union
européenne sont également de l'Alliance
atlantique et que pour la
majorité de nos partenaires européens
notamment d'Europe centrale et orientale
la sécurité c'est d'abord l'Alliance
Atlantique depuis son lancement lors du
sommet Fran britannique de SaintMalo il
y a 10 ans l'Europe de la défense a
beaucoup progressé des structures telles
que l'étatmajor européen le comité
politique et de sécurité corops ou le
Comité militaire ont été créés 23
mission civiles et militair ont été
lancé comme la dernière opération de
Lefort au Tchad première opération
européenne sans l'aide de l'OTAN et avec
la participation de qure hélicoptères et
de 100 militaires russes nous y
reviendrons opération qui est prise en
compte par le nuU depuis le 15 mars une
mutualisation progressive de nos
capacités de défense avec des résultats
probants un programme satellitaire
européen une coopération navale une
modernisation des flottes d'hélicoptères
existantes une formation commune des
militaires européens avec le projet
Erasmus militaire dont je suis en train
de rédiger un rapport dans le cadre de
l' une agencee européenne de la défense
a été mise en place afin de favoriser
l'émergence d'une industrie de défense
européenne qui a trouvé un accord avec
l'ca qui deviendra sa struture
opérationnelle comme j'avais suggéré il
y a 2 ans dans un rapport de l'UEO sur
cette agence des nouvelles merci
monsieur le ministre des nouvelles
avancées ont été enregistré sous
présidence française de l'Union
européenne au 2è semestre 2008 grâce à
votre action monsieur le ministre je
veux parler de la mise à jour de la
stratégie européenne de sécurité de la
mission d'observation de l'Union
européenne en Georgie et d'Erasmus déjà
cité et du lancement
de la première opération navale de lutte
contre la piraterie au large des côtes
somaliennes celle-ci avec des résultats
plus que probant comm nous en faisait
part le général bentej à une rayon du
cors et de l'UEO lundi dernier à
Bruxelles qui nous a indiqué qui nous a
indiqué qu'il y avait 10 fois moins
d'attaques réussis des pirates depuis
que cette opération existait bien sûr je
regrette que la mise en place il en
reste très peu monsieur le ministre
prenez prenez d'abord vos sources
vérifiez les chiffres j'espère que le
ministre vous répondra cette opération
est une opération promante je ne cite
que le général binj alors voyez quand
même les chos enfin ça ser à rien de
critiquer mais c'est au moins un
résultat pour ceux qui nav dans ces
zonesl je peux vous dire qu'ils sont
rassurés ils sont constamment branchés
dans leur bateau sur des internet ils
ont prévenus de tout les bateaux
arrivent al écoutez hein vous êtes pas
là-bas alors bien sûr je regrette que la
mise en place d'un véritable centre
européen de planification et de conduire
des opérations ce soit it heurté aux
rétissances britannique sa création
reste en effet indispensable pour
permettre à l'Union européenne de
planifier et de mener de manière
efficace et autonome les nombreuses
opérations dans lesquelles est engagé
mais je suis certain que cette idée
réussira tôt ou tard à s'imposer y
compris chez nos partenaires
britanniques ils évoluent eux aussi il
suffit de voir pour les quelques
collègues qui sont à l'UO de voir
l'évolution des parlementaires
britanniques au sein de l'UO sur la
surveillance de l' pass dans tout cela
l'attitude de la nouvelle administration
présidentielle américaine plus orientée
vers le Pacifique vers le Pacifique vers
l'Atlantique et surtout prise à la crise
financière ne veut plus être un
obstacle enfin je voudrais rappeler que
le traité de Lisbonne permettra de
nouveaux progrès dans ce domaine avec la
particulier la possibilité de lancer des
coopérations renforcées et des
coopérations structurées permanente les
États-membres qui le souhaitent et le
peuvent pourront donc décider
d'approfondir leur coopération en
matière de
défense empêché par les autres comme
c'est le cas actuellement nous devons
pour cela avancer avec une structure
ouverte reposant sur la volonté
politique des États qui veulent et
peuvent faire progresser la défense
européenne c'est la thèse de notre
collègue Fauchon qu'il a exprimé au sein
de la Commission européenne c'est de
cette manière que nous avons réussi
Schengen et la monnaie unique
j'ajouterai que la crise financière va
imposer des restrictions budgétaires qui
vont toucher les budgets de la défense
européen et vont par ricocher obliger
les Européens à mutualiser leurs efforts
ainsi le retour de la France dans l'OTAN
favorisera à la fois l'européanisation
de l'Alliance et la construction de
l'Europe de la défense en réalité la
seule crainte que nous pouvons avoir
c'est que la clarification de notre
position au sein de l'Alliance soit mal
comprise par certains de nos partenaires
extérieurs je pense en particulier à la
Russie qui conserve une attitude pour le
moins réservée à l'égard de cette
organisation c'est la raison pour
laquelle je considère que la la
réintégration pleine et entière de la
France au sein de l'Alliance doit
s'accompagner de gestes forts en
direction de ce pays visant à expliquer
notre position si je me félicite de la
récente ouverture de la Russie faite par
nouvelle administration présidentielle
américaine je je pense aussi que l'Union
européenne a un rôle à jouer pour
favoriser la mise en place d'une
coopération efficace avec la Russie en
matière de sécurité qu'il s'agisse du
projet d'implatation du système
américain de défense antimissile en
polne et en République tchèque ou de
l'idée d'élargir l'OTAN l'Ukraine et la
Georgie les Européens comme ils onont
fait à Budapest doivent avoir leur mots
à dire sur les questions qui les
concernent au premiers chefs et si l'on
veut réellement bâtir un espace de
sécurité sur le continent européen il
faudra bien trouver les voies et les
moyens pour y associer la Russie le
président russe Dimitri medvef a proposé
de mettre à plat le système de sécurité
en Europe et de conclure un nouveau Pact
de sécurité européen pourquoi ne pas
saisir cette opportunité et étudier avec
l'attention qu'elle mérite cette
proposition dès lors qu'elle ne remet
pas en cause les fondamentaux de
l'alliance de même il nous faut tirer
parti de la fin du gel des relations
entre la Russie et l'Otan depuis
l'affaire de Georgie en renouvelant le
dialogue autan Russie ces questions
messieurs les ministres seront-elles
abordé au sommet du 3 et 4 avril
construire un partenariat stratégique
entre l'Union européenne et la Russie
qui inclurait aussi bien les questions
énergétiques que les questions de
sécurité notamment dans notre voisinage
commun devient une évidence et comme
elle a montré dans la guerre
russo-georgienne de l'été dernier au
cours de sa présidence d'Union
européenne la France a un rôle
particulier à jouer pour favoriser
l'établissement d'un partenariat
stratégique entre l'Europe et la Russie
pour cela je préconise depuis longtemps
avec des collègues ici présents la
suppression des visas avec la Russie ce
serait un geste politique fort qui
favoriserait les échanges économiques
civiles culturels touristiques et
permettrait peut-être à la Russie de
perdre son comportement soviétique qui
l'a si fortement marqué et nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir discours
d'viant du président de la République le
8 octobre dernier qui a proposé un
espace économique commun entre l'Union
européenne et la Russie le monde bouge
terminerai là-dessus monsieur le
Président et nous devons pouger avec lui
l'Amérique se tourne vers le Pacifique
plus intéressé par la Chine que par
l'Europe et pour être moins intéressé
par l'Atlantique l'Europe se déplacee
vers l'est et nous croyons encore que
l'histoire sécrit à l'ouest nous parlons
de Bruxelles de Strasbourg et il faut
penser Berlin et Moscou nous songeons au
Balcans quand il faudrait s'adapter aux
réalités d'alie centrale prenez
simplement la façon dont nous regardons
la carte du continent euroasiatique on
voit dans notre salle de commission des
affaires étrangères il y a cette carte
là vous la regardez de façon Europe elle
est la Russie est excentrée et quand
vous regardez cette carte visuellement
du côté russe et bien vous voyez
l'énorme continent russe avec la Sibérie
l'Extrême Orient et tous les autres pays
et l'Europe n'est plus qu'une appendice
de ce continent et je crois que c'est un
élément géographique est important de
prendre en compte pour montrer que les
choses changent l'axe européen l'axe
européen se déplace vers l'Est ceci
oblige la France à avoir une politique
vers l'est plus volontarise dans
laquelle nous devons intégrer aussi bien
le développement des relations avec des
pays de l'Asie centrale le Kazakhstan le
tadikistan le kizistan l'oubékistan sont
des États en devenir tant dans le
domaine économique que sous la paix
stratégique et ils sont membres je vous
le rappelle et ils sont membres je vous
le rappelle du Conseil de l'Europe situé
à Strasbourg dont nous allons fêter le
60e anniversaire en octobre 2009 et nous
souhaitons d'ailleurs les membres du
Sénat participant au Conseil de l'Europe
que le Président de la République soit
présent je transmets cette demande à nos
amis
ministres bien sûr et je term làdessus
tout en confortant le L avec l'Allemagne
comme nous l'avons fait lors de la
rencontre des ministes franco-allemand
dernier mais là je m'adresse au de
ministre présent ici je ne peux que
regretter s'il m'écoute je ne peux que
regretter la rupture entre
arrivage et le rapochement des Allemands
avec les Russes sans que nous y soyons
associés et j'aimerais bien avoir des
réponses à si vous permettez en
conclusion monsieur président comme la
majorité du groupe de l'Union centriste
j'approuve pleinement la réintégration
pleine et entière de la France au sein
de l'Alliance atlantique ce monde est
interdépendant et les questions de
défenses comme d'énergie de climat nous
concernent tous et nous souhaitons que
de Vancouvert à Vladivostock nous
relevons ensemble les défis du futur
merci merci mon cher collègue la parole
est maintenant à Madame Michelle de
Messine pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et sénateur
du Parti de Gauche vous avez la parole
ma cher
collègue monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues cette
déclaration de politique étrangère qui
ne leure personne car tout le monde a
bien compris que le sujet en étit la
pleine réintégration de notre pays dans
le commandement militaire de l'OTAN a il
faut le dire le goût amè du réchauffé
nous partisons nous participons donc
aujourd'hui à une médiocre session de
rattrapage qui est également révélatrice
du mépris dans lesquels le gouvernement
tient le Sénat l'opposition et même
quelques membres de sa
majorité nous assistons depuis 15 jours
à la
démonstration que la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet dernier
indument d'ailleurs présenté par le
Président de la République et son
premier ministre comme devant donner
plus de pouvoir au Parlement n'était en
fait qu'un faux semblant qui masquait
mal une pratique
présidentielle omniprésente et
omnipotente en effet depuis plus d'un an
le président de la République Nicola
Sarkozi annonce hurbi et orbi de
préférence à l'étranger son intention
puis sa décision de réintégrer
pleinement notre pays dans le
commandement militaire de l'Alliance
atlantique d'abord en septembre 2007
devant le Congrès des
États-Unis puis en avril 2008 lors du
sommet de l'OTAN à Bucarest ou encore
lundi dernier en concluant un colloque à
l'école militaire et enfin jeudi dans
une notification officielle au
secrétaire général de cette
organisation mais face aux
interrogations aux réticences et à
l'opposition grandissante qui a pu
susciter cette décision le président et
son gouvernement ont refusé un véritable
débat et préféré la contrainte en
choisissant mardi dernier à l'Assemblée
nationale d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement au titre de l'article 491
de la Constitution sur une déclaration
de politique étrangère le Premier
ministre a ainsi privé la représentation
nationale d'un vote sur le problème en
discussion ce procédé comme le refus de
faire voter aujourd'hui le Sénat suivant
les nouvelles dispositions
constitutionnelles et
déloyales c'est l'aveu que vous
redoutter les voix discordantes dans
votre majorité en les obligeant ainsi à
rentrer dans le rang il démontre tout
simplement votre crainte du débat
démocratique sur une décision aussi
importante et aussi lourde de
conséquence puisqu'elle touche à l'un
des fondements de notre politique
étrangère et de
défense nous allons tranquillement
débattre n nous débattons d'ailleurs
tranquillement sans enjeu et dans
l'indifférence générale d'ailleurs
regardez les band de la presse sont
complètement vides d'une décision déjà
prise par le Président de la République
et sur laquelle nous n'aurons pas à nous
prononcer puisque nous ne voterons
pas nous avons donc compris maintenant
que si le président de la République et
vous-même chers collègues de la majorité
qui le soutenz parfois tant bien que mal
adopter cette attitude craintive c'est
bien aussi parce que cette décision est
difficile à justifier cela pour deux
raisons principales la première bien que
vous vous en défendiez et qu'aux yeux de
nos concitoyens le président de la
République s'en prend avant tout à l'un
des symboles forts de l'indépendance
nationale le contexte a certes changé
mais les motivations de la décision du
général de Gaul en
1966 restent je regrette elles restent
d'actualité il estimait à juste titre
que le commandement militaire intégré
était trop soumis aux seuls intérêts
stratégiques américains est-ce tellement
différent aujourd'hui il serait naïf de
croire que le nouveau concept
stratégique de de l'Alliance
actuellement en cours d'élaboration pour
prendre en compte les nouveaux risques
et les nouvelles menaces de notre époque
ne répondent pas au visés des
États-Unis le président Obama tout
sympathique qu'il soit défend avant tout
les intérêts de son
pays l'objectif reste de transformer
cette organisation en une alliance
globale tout àimute et l'argissant
progressivement son périmètre et sa zone
d'intervention substituant à l'ONU
lorsque celle-ci est
défaillante constitué autour d'un bloc
occidental dans lesquel les États-Unis
conserveraient leur influence
prépondérante elle apparaîtra toujours
aux yeux de nombreux pays et de nombreux
peuples comme leurs bras armé au service
de leur interventionnisme
hégémonique le mode des décisions
n'ayant pas changé au sein de
l'organisation et le nouveau concept
stratégique nétant pas encore
défini la décision de réintégrer
totalement le commandement militaire de
l'Alliance ne peut donc trouver de
justification certes depuis les années
90 nous avons progressivement réintégré
la quasi totalité des comités militaires
mais cela ne nous a pas donné pour
autant une plus grande influence au sein
de
l'Alliance ne prétendez donc pas que si
nous obtenions le commandement de
Norfolk chargé de évolution de la
doctrine de l'OTAN et le commandement
opérationnel de Lisbonne chargé de la
zone atlantique de l'Afrique et de la
force de réaction rapide nos généraux
puissent faire autre chose que
d'appliquer des concepts stratégiques
toujours défin à
Washington ces exemples montrent que le
problème n'est pas là où le président de
la République le placee en tentant de
rendre sa décision
anodine pour mieux la faire apparaître
comme l'aboutissement logique d'un
processus ainsi notre influence au sein
de l'organisation ne serait pas plus
grande mais en revanche nous perdrons à
coup sû dans le monde notre position
originale et singulière d'indépendance
et d'autonomie de décision qui nous
permet par exemple de contribuer à
apaiser les tensions sur le continent
africain ou dans l'Est européen de
garder le contact avec l'Iran ou de
dialoguer avec toutes les parties en
conflit au Proche
Orient en s'attaquant à l'un des
symboles de l'indépendance nationale
cette décision aura pour effet de
banaliser la voix de la France dans le
monde et de briser le consensus national
qui existait depuis 40 ans sur
l'autonomie de notre
défense la seconde raison avancé par le
Président de la République qui est
d'abandonner la spécificité de notre
statut sein de l'OTAN pour faire
progresser la défense européenne ne se
justifie pas plus dans ce domaine les 6
mois de présidence française n'ont pas
tenu leurs promesses tout le monde le
dit aucune avancée décisive n'a eu lieu
sur les questions fondamentales que sont
la création d'un état-major permanent de
planification des opérations ou bien une
agence européenne d'armement dotée d'une
réelle autorité vouloir ainsi réintégrer
toutes les structures militaires sans
avoir obtenu grand-chose c'est oré
gravement la possibilité de concrétiser
à l'avenir l'Europe de la défense c'est
aussi donné un signal négatif à ceux des
pays européens qui se satisfont d'une
défense à moindre coût sous le parapluie
de l'OTAN et qui ne veulent pas d'une
politique autonome de sécurité en
Europe pour notre part nous sommes
favorables à une organisation européenne
de sécurité collective émancipé de
l'OTAN fondé tout à la fois sur la
prévention des crises la résolution
multilatérale et politique des conflits
le respect du droit international et des
résolutions de l'ONU tout le contraire
de la décision du Président de la
République et de la construction
européenne proposée par le traité de
Lisbonne nous aurions souhaité que notre
pays prenne des initiatives fortes en
faveur de la sécurité internationale
pour éliminer les armes nucléaires et
toutes les armes de destruction massive
qu'il respecte et fasse respecter le
traité de nonpolifération qu'il crée une
dynamique de désarmement général qu'il
contribue à instaurer un contrôle public
national et international sur le
commerce des armes c'est ce débat que
nous aurions voulu avoir c'est sur ces
questions qui traite les intérêts
fondamentaux de notre pays de sa
sécurité de l'équilibre du monde que le
le Sénat aurait dû se
prononcer monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
de la majorité votre soumission au
président de la République vous a fait
manquer cette
occasion merci ma cher collègue la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur André
dulet orateur du groupe de l'Union pour
un mouvement
populaire
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues nous sommes réunis cet
après-midi après la déclaration du
Premier ministre sur la politique
étrangère de la France il en va des
ambitions de la France sur la scène
internationale c'est dans cette optique
spécifique qu'il convient d'aborder la
réintégration de la France au sein du
commandement militaire de l'OTAN et ce
dans le cadre de l'application stricte
de la Constitution la décision du
Président de la République poursuit un
objectif simple celui de la cohérence
une cohérence qui nécessite parfois des
réajustements il ne s'agit pas d'autre
chose nul ne peut nier le rôle aussi
majeur que particulier de notre pays sur
la scène
internationale une place et une action
qui sont le fruit de notre histoire de
nos valeurs et qui sont devenus une
tradition la diplomatie française dans
le monde est le résultat d'une ambition
que nous devons garder à l'esprit la
France représente sur la scène
internationale une référence à la
hauteur des idées qu'elle défend et
l'action du Président de la République
en a fait la la démonstration tant au
darrefour que dans la crise geéorgienne
de l'été
dernier on peut en parler la
France oui la France au sein de l'Union
européenne et lors de sa présidence a
joué un rôle moteur dans le règlement de
ce dernier conflit la France a agi tout
en gardant sa spécificité en restant
fidèle à ses principes l'amitié n'exclut
jamais la franchise la crise de Gaza
constitue un autre exemple significatif
de notre politique étrangère et un
aboutissement des liens de la France
avec les pays du monde arabe si beaucoup
se sont étonnés lorsque le président de
la République a reçu Monsieur Bachar
al-Assad en juillet 2008 personne ne
peut aujourd'hui nier le bénéfice de nos
relations diplomatiques avec la Syrie en
soutien de l'initiative égyptienne nos
relations diplomatiques ont en effet
permis d'établir un dialogue indirect
néanmoins capital entre les partis en
présence FEM non on ne l'oublie pas de
favoriser le rapprochement entre la
Syrie et le Liban qui après 30 ans vient
d'ouvrir une ambassade à Damas et de
créer les conditions propices à
l'engagement de pourparler afin
d'instaurer un cesser le feu en vue
d'une paix durable dans la région et en
y associant et en responsabilisant les
principaux pays de la zone mais notre
politique étrangère ne se limite pas à
la gestion et aux résolutions de crise
le président de la République entend
développer notre diplomatie bien au-delà
de nos sphère d'influence habituelle
c'est oui parfaitement aussi parce que
l'Arctique et l'Antarctique sont deux
zones du globe qui vont intéresser
l'ensemble des pays
développés le président de la République
entend développer notre diplomatie bien
au-delà de nos sphères d'influence
habituelle ces déplacements au Brésil au
Mexique et la restauration de nos liens
avec Cuba sont la preuve d'une
diplomatie ambitieuse et indépendante
propre depuis toujours à la France
or mes chers collègues à écouter
certains en réintégrant le commandement
militaire de l'OTAN nous abandonnerions
notre liberté en matière de politique
étrangère spécificité si propre à la
France nous braderions l'héritage du
général de Gaulle et de la 5e
République notre diplomatie serait-elle
irréédiablement moins active mes chers
collègues rapprochement avec la
situation de
1966 est une approche erronée du
contexte géopolitique dans lequel nous
vivons nous avons pu lire bien des
analyses dans la presse nous avons
entendu de nombreux points de vue sur
les ondes évoquant la décision de
1966 mais je n'ai pas entendu un point
de contexte essentiel force de rappeler
que la décision du général de Gaulle a
été également motivé par une réalité en
1966 le seul Français accueillait des
bases militaires américaines avec en
perspective l'installation de forces
nucléaire américaine de plus la logique
des blocs et par conséquent les
institutions de l'Alliance ne nous
permettaiit pas la latitude qu'elles
offrent aujourd'hui depuis l'Alliance a
connu de nombre nus mutations elle
évolue en fonction des menaces
aujourd'hui la guerre froide est
terminée bon nombre d'anciens pays
satellite de l'URS ont intégré
l'alliance certains sont membres de
l'Union et membres de l'Alliance ils
doivent comme nous faire face à des
menaces non étatiques et de plus en plus
difficiles à maîtriser ils sont
confrontés à de nouvelles menaces et
doivent assumer de nouvelles missions
telles que la lutte contre le terrorisme
lutte contre la prolification des armes
de destruction massiv lutte contre les
trafics internationaux lutte contre la
piraterie internationale aujourd'hui
l'Alliance atlantique doit garantir la
sécurité de ses membres bien au-delà de
leurs frontières géographique en 2009 le
concept du commandement militaire
intégré tend également à évoluer et il
doit être adapté depuis la fin du monde
bipolaire en aucun cas l'intégration au
commandement militaire de l'OTAN
n'implique la mutualisation de nos
forces par ailleurs l'alliance dispose
uniquement des forces que les nations
veulent bien lui fournir et qui sont
placés provisoirement sous l'autorité du
cheip rappelons que les États-membres
sont libres d'engager ou non leurs
troupes dans les opérations de
l'Alliance selon les impératifs de leur
propr politique étrangère l'Allemagne
par exemple a refusé d'envoyer ses
troupes en Irak l'OTAN pas plus qu'une
autre organisation internationale n'est
une instance où les pays membres
seraient tenus de définir leur politique
étrangère il convient donc de
dédramatiser ce retour au sein du
commandement militaire ce n'est qu'un
réajustement proportionnel à l'action et
à la participation de la France au sein
des opérations de l'OTAN mes chers
collègues pourquoi la France 3e
contributeur en moyen financier 4e
contributeur ça a déjà été dit en moyens
humains dans les opérations de l'OTAN
devrait-elle rester en dehors des
décisions de commandement alors qu'il
s'agit de nos hommes qu'on envoie sur le
terrain il est temps de faire preuve de
cohérence notre participation au sein de
l'Union européenne a-t-elle contraint
notre politique étrangère bien au
contraire à la tête de la présidence
européenne la France a donné une
nouvelle impulsion à la diplomatie
européenne son indépendance diplomatique
n'a pas été remise en cause de sur croix
elle y a apporté ses valeurs et sa
vision par ailleurs notre décision a été
favorablement accueillie par nos
partenaires européen en effet le
maintien de la France hors du
commandement militaire de l'OTAN pour
pouvait alimenter une certaine méfiance
de la part des membres de l'Union alors
même que la France milite en faveur de
la construction d'une véritable
politique de défense
commune cette clarification de notre
statut mettra un terme à une idée que se
font de nous certains de nos partenaires
européens idée selon laquelle la
politique européenne de la France
répondrait à un agenda fantôme ceux qui
s'agitent et qui voient dans le choix du
président de la République la mort de la
défense européenne je voudrais leur dire
que l'Europe de la défense et l'Alliance
ne sont pas en concurrence il est temps
d'expliciter une certaine
complémentarité entre les deux
organisations et d'y adapter notre
politique de défense nos programmes
d'équipement et notre politique
industrielle c'est exactement ce qu'a
réaffirmé le président de la République
au travers du Livre blanc de la défense
c'est là la démonstration d'une
véritable vision de la politique
étrangère de la France dans les années à
venir
oui ben vous y avez participé au Livre
Blanc chers collègu donc vous pouvez
mesurer les efforts fait une politique
étrangère en phase avec le contexte
géopolitique actuel et en phase avec
l'alliance qui est à un tournant de son
histoire c'est l'enjeu du sommet de quel
Strasbourg la semaine prochaine la
révision du concept stratégique de
l'OTAN est une occasion historique que
nous ne pouvons pas laisser passer
contrairement à ce que pens certains la
France ne va pas signer un chèque en
blanc pour le comprendre pour le
comprendre il nous faut prendre en
compte la confluence de paramètres
essentiels sans pour autant céder à
l'Obamania je rappelle que les
États-Unis ont eux aussi rendez-vous
avec l'Alliance le président américain a
clairement énoncer que son pays
engagerait un dialogue renforcé avec les
alliés nous ne pouvons rester sourd et
inactif face à cet appel au
multilatéralisme nous devons être un
moteur pour les 21 pays membres de
l'Union sur les 27 qui sont membres de
l'Alliance c'est l'occasion d'EUR an
iser l'OTAN en opérant un meilleur
équilibrage en matière de coordination
des opérations entre l'Alliance et
l'Union à un moment où les forces de
l'Union européenne prennent le relais de
celle de l'Alliance sur certains
théâtres d'opération à un moment où
l'Alliance a besoin d'une réforme
structurelle à l'heure actuelle trop
nombreux sont les pays de l'Union
européenne et membres de l'OTAN qui
s'abr qui s'abrite derrière le parapluie
sécuritaire qu'offre l'alliance grâce à
la garantie d'un engagement des forces
américaines en cas d'agression il est
primordial que ces pays mettent en œuvre
une réelle politique nationale de
défense tout en développant des niches
de spécialisation comme l'a notamment
fait la Pologne qui a envoyé des forces
au Tchad dont les retombées profiteront
aussi à la peste pour cela il est
tempant que la France obtienne des
responsabilités et des représentations
au sein de l'Alliance afin de participer
aux orientations stratégiques telles que
le renouvellement des doctrines et
l'amélioration des capacités la conduite
des opérations sur les théâtres ou sont
les personnels militaires de l'Alliance
sur ces sujets précisément la France
peut et doit faire prévaloir son
expérience en terme de gestion des
conflits à l'heure où les seuls
intervention militaire ne sont plus des
solutions notre expertise et nos
capacités d'analyse largement reconnu
par nos alliés peuvent influer les
futures doctrines de l'Alliance la
situation en Afghanistan et en Iran en
Irak nous le rappelle chaque jour les
Alliés doivent se souvenir que la
résolution des conflits au 21e siècle
passe par une vision globale reposant
sur les principes fondamentaux de vision
et d'anticipation de sortie de crise
c'est aussi cela la vision de la France
oui ben grâce à vous alors en réponse à
ceux qui prétendent que la réintégration
du commandement militaire de l'OTAN rime
avec une aliénation de notre politique
étrangère ou de notre défense je veux
rappeler l'excellence de nos troupes en
opération sur le terrain le comportement
de nos soldats en Afghanistan et au
Liban à qui je souhaite en votre nom
rendre hommage dans cet hémicycle est la
preuve que notre
spécificité reconnue par nos alliés et
par les partenaires de l'Alliance est
qualifié d'une certaine French Touch nos
relations diplomatiques n'ont jamais été
entravées aussi bien avec les pays du
monde arabe qu'avec les pays d'Asie ou
du continent africain et ce n'est pas en
ayant des responsabilités accrues au
sein des structures militaires de l'Otan
à la mesure de son engagement sur la
scène internationale que notre pays
renira ce qu'il représente nous ne
doutons pas que la France continuera
d'honorer ses valeurs et ses traditions
tout en préservant son indépendance
stratégique au sein du commandement
militaire intégré de l'OTAN en cours de
renouvellement je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur Emer
de montesquou pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues notre intégration du
commandement militaire de l'OTAN est
actée ainsi ce débat
postériori soulligne un manque de
considération pour le Sénat et une
contradiction avec une réforme
constitutionnelle qui devait donner plus
de poids au
Parlement plus que le retour à l'OTAN
dont la symbolique selon nos partenaires
européens entraîne un débat dépassé à
peine compréhensible et particulièrement
abstrait il s'agit de savoir dans quel
système de défense multilatérale nous
intégrer car il serait dérisoire de conf
notre défense dans un splendide
isolement le contexte militaire n'a
aucun rapport avec celui de 1949 où
l'ennemi était désigné aujourd'hui il
est protéiforme et les conflits
n'opposent plus des divisions armées les
unes aux autres il ne s'agit pas non
plus 43 ans après surtout pour ceux qui
à l'époque se sont opposés à lui d'être
fidèle à la pensée du général de Gaulle
don le charisme envahissait le champ
médiatique de son immense présence
immobile notre objectif de sécurité
s'inscrit naturellement et politiquement
dans une défense
européenne la problématique est la
suivante les pays de l'Union les pays de
son Orient particulier et la Grande
Bretagne surtout sont-ils prêts à
intégrer une organisation de défense
européenne
distingue de celle de
l'UTAN de toute évidence est non nous ne
serions pas suivi par nos
partenaires queles que soi nos
préventions ou plutôt nos réticences
nous devons appartenir à une alliance
militaire pour que notre défense soit
crédible et efficace et nous n'avons pas
d'alternative à l'utant nous y pèserons
certainement plus en l'intégrant et en
obtenant des commandements mais cette
intégration doit se faire dans un
partenariat équilibré Europe Amérique du
Nord quelle doit être notre
exigence ne pas être le bras armé de la
diplomatie
américaine qui malgré les nouvelles
orientations du président Obama
conservera vraisemblablement ses
fondamentaux et peut-être même cette
doctrine des alliances à géométrie
variable qui avait si profondément vexé
leur indéfectible alliés britannique
lors de la guerre
d'Irak lors de ce conflit l'Allemagne
allié essentiel des États-Unis
totalement intégré dans l'OTAN a
démontré son indépendance vis-à-vis de
la diplomatie
américaine nous pouvons considérer cet
exemple comme une garantie
essentielle faisons aussi preuve
d'imagination il ne doit plus s'agir
d'un Traité de l'Atlantique Nord et nous
devons trouver une appellation
différente de celle de 1949 où l'ennemi
désigné était l'Union
soviétique nous devons en effet gommer
toute confusion entre Union soviétique
et Russie
aujourd'hui la Russie est devenue le
partenaire de l'Union européenne non
seulement dans le domaine de l'énergie
mais aussi dans la résolution des
conflits elle est essentielle au Groupe
de Minsk pour tenter de résoudre les
problèmes me du Caucase au quartet pour
résoudre ceux de Moyen-Orient et pour
approcher d'une solution en
Afghanistan si nous intégrons le
commandement militaire mobilisons nos
partenaires pour que les Américains ne
provoquent pas la Russie en implantant
des batteries de missile en Pologne et
en Tchéquie et montrons notre réticence
à l'entrée de la Georgie et de l'Ukraine
dans
l'OTAN comme nous l'avons déjà fait de
concert avec
l'Allemagne la contrepartie de ces
erreurs a été une crispation russe et
entre autres une augmentation de son
budget défense et l'ouverture des ports
vézuéliens à sa flotte mettons en place
des liens étroits et même une véritable
coordination entre l'OTAN et l'OSCE qui
servent de trait d'union de Brest à
l'Oural prévenons les moments de fortes
tension à venir entre l'Ukraine et la
Russie lorsque le bail de Sébastopol
touchera à sa fin ayons donc à l'esprit
que jamais la Russie n'abandonnera ce
port qui est russe depuis Catherine i un
équilibre entre le pilier américain et
le pilier européen doit nous permettre
de manifester l'indépendance de la
politique étrangère européenne et de
retrouver l'état d'esprit du général de
Gaulle soulignant à la fois l'amitié
exceptionnelle de la France avec
États-Unis et prononçant en même temps
le discours de Pnom Pen mise en garde
solennelle stigmatisant une profonde
différence d'analyse de la politique
internationale nous avons trois raisons
objectives de réussir cette nouvelle
organisation de l'OTAN et de revenir à
la définition originelle du président
Truman le devoir des grands état est de
servir et non de dominer le monde
l'Europe sait désormais qu' doit compter
d'abord sur elle les deux pays qui
investissent le plus dans une défense
conséquente la Grande-Bretagne 2 % et la
France 1,8 % du PIB ont mis en place les
prémisses de cette défense de l'Union à
saint-malot le budget américain de la
Défense 4 % du PIB source de nombreux
déséquilibres financiers mondiaux ne
pourra survivre à la crise les
États-Unis n'ont plus les moyens de leur
hégémonie l'ubris américain nous avons
raison car nous sommes les plus forts
source de tant de catastroph ne sera
plus
accepté pour conclure je citerai les
propos de brunislav
jéremc il ne faut pas sous-estimer le
potentiel des structures et des
procédures dont dispose l'UTAN mais elle
devrait être une structure de sécurité
européenne pour cela j'ose dire que le
rôle de la France et des décisions Fran
sont absolument
capital merci mon cher collègue la
parole est maintenant à Madame Dominique
voet rattaché au groupe
socialiste vous avez la parole chers
collègu monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre messieurs les ministres
mesdames et
messieurs décision est donc prise quoi
qu'il se dise dans cette hémicycle au
cours de ce débat un débat sans
enjeu la décision du Président de la
République a été annoncé largement sans
négliger les grandes proclamations sur
l'indépendance nationale sans oublier
non plus le discours d'édification de sa
propre gloire qui décidément caractérise
l'actuelle
présidence elle a été notifiée au
secrétaire général de l'Alliance
atlantique et à nos partenaires la
décision est prise et la question se
pose à nouveau du rôle du Sénat dont il
semblerait qu'on ait prétendu redorer le
lustre pour mieux pouvoir
l'humilier le président de la République
a longuement exposé le 11 mars dernier
les raisons pour lesquelles il entendait
voir revenir la France dans le
commandement militaire intégré de l'OTAN
à rebour de la position originale de
notre pays maintenue depuis
1966 par les quatre successeurs du
général de Gaulle à la présidence
l'impression qui domine lorsqu'on relit
ce discours c'est ce sentiment
pardonnez-moi que la position qu'il
soutient est singulièrement en retard
sur les enjeux du monde évidemment on y
trouve les passages obligés sur les
risques de demain l'énergie le climat
les ressources en eau mais le discours
du président de la République semble
parler du monde d'hier et
pourtant un concept stratégique n'est
pertinent que s'il est adapté à la
situation non pas que connaît notre pays
mais qu'il va connaître car non
seulement on doit pas avoir de retard
dans la définition d'un concept
stratégique mais de préférence il faut
avoir de l'avance ces mots mesdames et
messieurs sont du président de la
République lui-même je suis comme vous
sans doute désolé qu'il n'a pas pris au
sérieux ses propres recommandation car
la décision dont il est aujourd'hui
question répond à tout sauf précisément
aux enjeux de demain l'Organisation du
Traité de l'Atlantique Nord n'est pas à
la hauteur des défis nés par exemple de
la crise climatique des temps sur les
ressources énergétiques dont plus
personne ne conteste l'importance
stratégique et je vais vous le dire
c'est logique qui pourrait sérieusement
penser qu'un outil né de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale un outil qui a connu ses
plus belles heures sous la guerre froide
pourrait sans réforme profonde être
encore adapté au monde que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui que
penserions-nous alors que nous ne
cessons de rappeler par la voix du
président de la République que
décidément non nous n'entrons pas dans
la logique de guerre des civilisation
que penserions-nous si demain
d'autres s'organisaient en alliance
militaire régionale accepterions-nous si
facilement l'idée d'un ensemble
militaire asiatique par exemple ne
serions-nous pas tentés d'y voir une
regrettable entorse à la globalisation
de la prévention des conflits à la
préférence affirmée aux efforts
diplomatiques multilatéraux sur les
réponses militaires d'un seul acteur
fut-il un acteur collectif regroupant un
ensemble de pays qui à l'échelle du
monde quand même se ressemble beaucoup
j'en fait le Paris si d'autres États
dans une autre R du monde s'essayer
demain à constituer ce que nous avons
nous-mêm mérité de l'histoire mais que
nous cherchons moins que jamais à
modifier si d'autres États voulaient
dans une autre région du monde eux aussi
construire un concept stratégique hors
des Nations Unies nous serions tentés
d'y voir un recul inadapté à notre
époque mais il semble hélas que ce qui
vaut pour les autres ne vaut pas pour
nous on a entendu dans votre bouche
monsieur le ministre tout et son
contraire la décision serait au fond
anodine entérinant une ité de fait et
puis quelques instants plus tard c'est
une condition cinequanone d'un maintien
de l'influence française dans le monde
mais ces arguments répétés encore et
encore ne sont pas plus solides ni plus
convaincants parce qu'ils sont
ressassés on nous dit que le retour
français de la complet de la France dans
l'UTAN favoriserait par une sorte de rus
de l'histoire l'émergence d'une défense
européenne mais pourquoi donc la
présidence française de l'Union a-t-elle
sur ce point échoué alors que la
décision la France était déjà connu
c'était pourtant une priorité de la
présence française on allait voir ce
qu'on allait voir et on a vu des
décisions intéressant sur les questions
d'équipement mais une vraie panne une
panne politique une panne stratégique
sur le dossier de création d'une cellule
de commandement et de planification au
sein de la politique européenne de
sécurité et de défense parce que parmi
nos partenaires européens nous ne nous
nous nous sommes en difficulté les
blocages qui freinent l'émergence d'une
véritable défense européenne n'ont rien
à voir avec avec le positionnement de
tel ou tel membre y compris la France
vis-à-vis de l'OTAN ces blocages sont
internes à l'Union européenne et il est
au mieux naïf au pire mensonger de
laisser croire qu'on le surmontera en
déplaçant le débat sur l'alliance en
vérité comment mieux illustrer la panne
européenne qu'en rappelant que le vetau
opposé à la mise en place d'un étatmajor
européen est justement qu'il ferait
double emploi avec celui de l'OTAN alors
je ne crois pas moi contenu des
difficultés budgetires qui sont les
nôtres que nous pourrons à la fois nous
engager financièrement pour faire à la
fois plus d'ut temp et plus de défense
européenne je ne crois pas non plus que
le la France qui avait fini au fil du
temps par voir reconnaître sa position
singulière au cas par cas pourrait sans
aucune négociation sur une base
totalement unilatérale gagner quoi que
ce soit à renoncer à cette position
singulière on me dit qu'un retour
complet dans l'UTAN n'empêchera pas la
France dans le dans le futur de faire
valoir une voix différente comme l'a
fait l'Allemagne au moment de l'invasion
de l'Irak mais rien non plus ne me
laisse aujourd'hui penser que Nicolas
Sarkozi sera l'homme qui saura dire non
après tout le président de la République
a jusqu'ici montré plus d'empressement à
s'aligner qu'à résister il n'avait pas
caché son accord avec les désastreuse
stratégie de George buouche cette
décision mesdames et messieurs ressemble
en tout au fait du prince et les prise
sans que soit prise en compte la vie du
Parlement dont on ne sait si on le
craint ou si on s'en moque
elle est prise sans la vie des Français
qui sont stupéfaits à Strasbourg de
constater une mobilisation policière
impressionnante pour faire taire ou
dissimuler toute trace de contestation
sans aucune consigne de la préfecture
n'est-ce pas quel ail s'il nous avait
été offert de voter aujourd'hui vous
dotez monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le ministre ce de de ce
qu'aurait été notre vote privé de ce
droit il nous reste celui de vous
avertir vous faites un très dangereux
Paris vous prenez un risque dont
personne ne peut mesurer tout à fait les
conséquences loin de renforcer la
défense européenne vous prenez le risque
de l'avir reculé pour très longtemps
c'est une grave décision la façon dont
elle a été prise dit long sur l'estime
dans laquelle vous tenez le Parlement
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et même
d'une certaine façon les questions de
défense qui sont des questions civiques
des questions citoyennes nous Pons le
prix de cette décisions dans les années
qui viennent je regrette tout ce temps
perdu pour vous pour moi pour nous tous
je vous
remercie merci ma chère collègue la
parole maintenant à Monsieur Xavier Pat
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues le
gouvernement vient de réaffirmer de
manière très claire les grands principes
qui déterminent son action en matière de
politique étrangère nous avons constaté
au cours des derniers mois que la France
avait su faire entendre sa voix et
défendre avec beaucoup d'énerg
sa vision et ses propositions sur tous
les dossiers déterminants la crise
financière le changement climatique le
Proche Orient le conflit en geéorgie la
relance de la construction
européenne je suis convaincu que si la
France choisit aujourd'hui au terme
d'une évolution de près de 20 ans
c'est-à-dire de participer pleinement au
structures de l'OTAN ce n'est pas pour
renoncer au message qu'elle porte sur la
scène
internationale ni pour brider le rôle de
sa diplomatie bien contraire je ne
reviendrai pas sur les transformations
qui ont fortement modifié depuis la fin
de la guerre froide le visage de l'OTAN
ni sur tous les éléments qui fond de la
France l'un des principaux acteurs l'un
des principaux contributeurs de cette
organisation cette situation aené
logiquement à s'interroger sur l'intérêt
de vouloir rester en dehors d'instance
ou de structures dans lesquelles sont
préparées sont mises en œuvre des
décisions qui influent directement sur
les opérations nous sommes engagés au
demeurant comme l'a dit le Premier
ministre la semaine dernière il s'agit
de franchir la dernière marche d'un
rapprochement qui est devenu très étroit
depuis les opérations dans les Balcans à
la fin des années
90 je crois pour ma part qu'il est
important de souligner que ce
renforcement de notre présence dans les
structures de l'Alliance atlantique
n'altère à rien les fondements de notre
politique étrangère et de notre
politique de défense le président de la
République a rappelé le 11 mars les
trois principes fondamentaux qui
sauraient qui ne sauraient être remis en
cause la liberté d'appréciation des
autorités politiques françaises
l'indépendance nucléaire de la France et
la liberté de décision sur l'engagement
de nos forces personne ne peut douter
que l'indépendance nucléaire de la
France sera préservée non seulement
parce que notre pays reste en dehors du
groupe des plans nucléaires de l'OTAN
instance dans le rôle est d'ailleurs
très limité mais surtout parce que la
dissuasion conserve un rôle essentiel
dans notre stratégie de
défense c'est ce que vient de confirmer
le Livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale alors que le projet
de loi de programmation prévoit les
moyens permettant d'assurer la
crédibilité de notre dissuasion dans la
durée notre dissuasion indépendante
reste la garantie ultime de notre
sécurité elle est aussi et elle restera
un élément très important de notre
stature sur le plan international la
dissuasion concourt à la liberté
d'appréciation des autorités françaises
autre principe fondamental rappelé par
le chef de l'État cette liberté
d'appréciation nous entendons également
la renforcer au cours des prochaines
années en développant les nos moyens
propres de connaissance et
d'anticipation des situations pour
reprendre la terminologie la
terminologie du Livre blanc qui en fait
sa grande priorité le rôle moteur que
nous jouons en Europe dans le domaine
spatial et les projets ambitieux de
satellite d'observation et de
renseignement que nous avons programmé
me paraissent également parfaitement
illustré notre volonté de conserver
l'entière maîtrise de nos choix nous
savons l'apport crucial de ces capacités
pour l'autonomie de décision dans les
situations de crise en se donnant les
moyens de son autonomie la France
démontre je le crois qu'elle ne confond
pas alliance avec dépendance ou
subordination enfin je voudrais terminer
en soulignant la nécessité pour notre
pays de continuer à œuvrer pour l'Europe
de la défense il en va de l'efficacité
de nos efforts de défense il en va de la
pérennité de nos industries il en va
surtout de la capacité de l'Europe à
agir par elle-même lorsqu'elle le
souhaite je crois que le Président de la
République et le gouvernement ont
démontré par par leurs actes tout au
long de ces derniers mois que la France
ne renonçait pas à son ambition de
renforcer la politique européenne de
sécurité et de défense c'est me
semble-t-il rendre un mauvais service à
la cause européenne que de vouloir
opposer alliance atlentique et Europe de
la défense car il est évident que bien
peu de nos partenaires sont disposés à
abandonner l'une au profit de l'autre
comment convaincre nos partenaires
européens qui pour une vingtaine d'entre
eux 21 exactement sont membres à part
entière de l'OTAN de bâtir avec nous une
politique de défense commune si nous
posons comme principe absolu que la
pleine participation au structur de
l'OTAN est incompatible avec notre
vision des choses en participant aux
structures de l'Alliance sur le même
pied que les autres alliés nous
apportons une clarification qui ne peut
qu'améliorer l'proche commune entre
Européens en conclusion il me semble que
la décision que nous venons de prendre
sur l' temp est cohérente avec le rôle
que nous jouons dans
l'organisation et avec notre ambition
européenne s'il vous plaît mais bien sûr
sans remettre en cause les grands axes
de l'indépendance de notre
politique nous devons saisir les moyens
supplémentaires que nous donnera une
présence renforcée pour faire valoir nos
positions tant sur l'avenir de l'OTAN au
moment où va se préparer la révision de
son concept stratégique que sur la
conduite des opérations mes chers
collègues messieurs les ministres je
suis convaincu que la France comme elle
a toujours fait continuera à faire
entendre sa voix et à jouer tout son
rôle au service de la paix et de la
sécurité merci mon ch
collèg Monsieur Jean-Pierre ch pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social et
européen vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président messieur
les ministres mes chers
collègues personne ne nous a
demandé de réintégrer l'organisation
militaire de l'OTAN ni les États-Unis ni
nos alliés
européens cette décision solitaire du
président de la République a été prise
sans débat préalable à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement a pris sa
majorité en otage en utilisant l'article
491 de la
Constitution au Sénat il n'y a eu ni
débat ni vote et s'il y avait eu un
véritable
débat sanctionné par un vote et un
véritable débat dans le pays le résultat
vous le savez bien eû été tout
autre un mot sur l'évolution du contexte
stratégique depuis
1966 à l'époque le général de gaô
craignait que la doctrine américaine de
la riposte graduée fit de la France un
champ de
bataille mais il craignait aussi que
nous ne fussions entraînés dans des
guerres qui ne seraient pas les nôtres
ainsi la guerre du Vietnam qu'il
fustigea dans son discours de Pnom Pen
cette éventualité et je m'adresse à la
majorité n'a rien perdu de son actualité
le risque de nouvelle guerre s'est déjà
concrétisé notamment en Irak et en
Afghanistan nul ne sait ce qu' en sera
demain au Proche Orient en Iran au
Pakistan dans le Caucase ou en Asie de
l'Est
le président de la République a évoqué
en reprenant les analyses du Livre blanc
sur la défense monsieur le ministre de
la Défense l'apparition de nouvelle
menaces
liée à la mondialisation concept
flou qui énonce un certain nombre de
phénomènes contradictoires qui
caractérise le monde d'aujourd'hui mais
qui n'explique rien cette analyse
néglige les
et l'évolution de la géographie de la
puissance la crise actuelle crise
financière et économique mais aussi en
lisement militaire des États-Unis au
Moyen-Orient montre que ceux-ci ne sont
plus en mesure de dominer seul le reste
de la planète et peut-être même de le
dominer du tout la montée de pays
milliardaires en hommees comme la Chine
et l'Inde mais aussi le retour de la
Russie et plus généralement d'anciennees
nation où
l'émergence de nouvelle puissance
structureront le paysage stratégique
beaucoup plus que le concept valise de
mondialisation à l'oré de cet temps
nouveau le président de la République a
choisi de mettre la France dans le
sillage américain en énonçant que nous
appartenons d'abord à la famille
occidentale et en oubliant que nous
appartenons d'abord à la famille humaine
et le risque est grand de
voir aant courir derrière l'ONU comme si
elle pouvait devenir une
onubis alors que nous siégeons au
Conseil permanent du Conseil de sécurité
au côté de puissan comme la Russie et la
Chine c'est un contresens géopolitique
que cette décision que nous demandent en
fait les Américains c'est d'être leurs
auxiliaires dans la tâche qu'il
s'assigne de refonder leur leadership
permettez-moi de vous citer monsieur
breginski toujours affluent dans les
milieux
démocrates tout en arguant qu'il ne sont
pas en mesure d'intervenir militairement
les Européens dit Monsieur brginski
insistent pour prendre part aux
décisions même si les États-Unis demeure
la première puissance mondiale nous
avons besoin d'une alliance forte avec
l'Europe pour optimiser notre affluence
respective et il ajoute je soulligne
l'Europe peut faire beaucoup plus sans
déployer des forces surumain
et sans acquérir une autonomie telle
qu'elle met en danger ses liens avec
l'Amérique tout est dit on peut être
plus clair l' temp est un moyen de
solliciter davantage la contribution
militaire des Européens à des opérations
dont chacun sait très bien qu'elles sont
décidé à
Washington tout en empêchant que
l'Europe se dote d'une défense autonome
or celle-ci est la condition d'une
politique étrangère
indépendante
la décision du Président de la
République obéit donc à une logique
américaine celle d'un partage accru du
fardeau mais nullement des décisions au
sein d'une alliance qu'il domine
absolument vous me connaissez messieur
les ministre le poids des entraînements
est celui des symboles 700 officiers
dans les état-majors de l'OTAN cela crée
un tropisme dans nos armées qu'on
déshabitue ainsi de pensé nationale
l'argument selon lequel l'Allemagne la
Turquie en 2003 aurait pu dire non c'est
un fusil à un coup quand on est quand on
est intégré assis en permanence à la
même table on ne peut dire non tout le
temps le président de la République
laisse à penser que la France en
envoyant des officiers généraux dans les
états-majors et pas seulement des soldat
sur le terrain pourra peser sur les
décisions c'est un sophisme chacun sait
très bien que les vraies décisions se
prennent à la Maison Blanche vous me
connaissez enfin et surtout le poids des
symboles de depuis 1966 la France avait
maintenu une distance vis-à-vis de
l'OTAN qui la faisait regarder comme un
pays non aligné bref indépendant et
c'est à cela que vous allez mettre fin
vous protestez en disant qu'il ne s'agit
que d'une impression que vous restez
indépendant mais une impression en
politique internationale c'est
tout le président de la République a
justifié la réintégration complète de la
structure militaire de l'OTAN par
l'argument de la défense européenne nous
faisons plus blanc que blanc nous
dissiperions les suspicions qui auraient
freiné les avancées de la dite défense
mais c'est là une vue bien naïve des
choses il n'y a pas de défense
européenne pour trois raisons parce que
les États-Unis ne le souhaitent pas
parce que les Britanniques se posent et
la mise sur pied d'une structure
d'état-major significative min
étrangères qui permettrait la
planification et la mise en œuvre
d'opérations proprement européenne et
enfin
troisièmement parce que les autres pays
européens ne sont pas prêts à faire les
effort de se défendre par eux-mêmes et
pour la France aussi le risque est grand
son effort de défense n'a jamais été
aussi faible que l'esprit de défense
lui-même à la longue se trouve atteint
parce que il n'y a pas d'esprit de
défense qui vaille en dehors de
l'indépendance alors le risque je vais
en terminer par là mais le risque c'est
que euh nous nous laissions entraîner
dans de nouvelles guerres ou dans de
nouvelles politiques qui ne soient pas
les nôtres pour reprendre l'expression
du général de Gaulle certes je ne m
cononnais pas tout l'intérêt des
nouvelles orientations du président
Obama mais celui-ci ne cache pas que son
intention c'est de refonder un nouveau
leadership américain d'ouvrir la voix à
un nouveau siècle
américain votre décision de
réintégration complète de l'OTAN accroit
le risque je le disais que nous laission
entraîner dans des guerres qui nous
seraient étrangères qui peut dire que
dans la crise profonde monde qui frappe
l'économie mondiale la guerre demain en
Iran ou ailleurs ne sera pas encore une
fois aux yeux de dirigeant aux abois le
moyen de forcer le
destin alors que nous nous apprêtons à
fermer une base militaire en Afrique
centrale traditionnelle zone d'influence
française mais aussi réservoir de
richesse qui suscite toutes les
convoitises nous ouvrons une nouvelle
base à Abu Dhabi dans le golfe région où
notre autonomie stratégique est nulle
avec la Chine grande puissance du 21e
siècle une brouille espérons le
passagère d peut-être à des impères ou à
des susceptibilités excessives peut-être
vous pourriez nous éclaairer sur ce
sujet vient obscurcir notre relation
mais qui peut croire que cette brouille
n'illustre pas aussi notre changement de
posture vis-à-vis des
États-Unis enfin je n'observe pas que
les États-Unis ont renoncé à faire
entrer un jour dans l' temp l'Ukraine et
la Géorgie ce jourl notre partenariat
stratégique avec la Russie deviendra
rétorique je conclus en disant que
l'indépendance nationale ne se définit
pas contre les États-Unis bien
évidemment pas on peut être indépendant
et d'autant mieux àiier des États-Unis
par exemple nous pourrions venir en aide
au président Obama dans un puissant
effort de relance coordonné à l'échelle
mondiale sur le plan économique c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu' nous demande mais dans
le monde multipolaire de demain il y a
place pour une diplomatie française
indépendante qui donnerait une voix à
l'Europe et contribuerait à l'existence
autant ou pas d'un pôle européen capable
de peser sur l'orientation de la
politique mondiale votre décision rendra
cet objectif beaucoup plus difficilement
accessible je vous le dis avec tristesse
merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Michel Boutan pour le
groupe
socialiste
avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues dans la lettre du 12 mars 2009
adressé aux sénateurs et signé des
caisseurs et et de vous-même monsieur le
Président du Sénat on peut lire le Sénat
se trouve aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins il est sur le plan
institutionnel il est aussi sur le plan
politique dans un contexte de regain
d'un certain
antiparlementarisme largement tourné
contre la Haute Assemblée fait nouveau
par rapport à d'autres
périodes et bien messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues le débat sur la
politique étrangère dans lequel nous
sommes censés don donner notre avis est
plutôt un faux débat voire un débat
stérile dans la mesure où la question du
retour de notre pays dans le
commandement intégré de l'Alliance
atlantique a déjà été
tranché de fait la manière cavalière
dont l'exécutif traite et je dirais
maltraite notre assemblée nourrit
l'antiparlementarisme en général et la
déconsidération du Sénat en
particuliervo
le président de la République à la date
du 20 mars dernier c'est-à-dire il y a 5
jours a confirmé et je cite que la
France a décidé de reprendre toute sa
place au sein de l'OTAN après le débat
au Parlement
français monsieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président le Sénat fait-il
encore partie du par
selon les termes de l'article 24 de la
Constitution quand le président de la
République Sensa veiller au respect de
la Constitution méprise à ce point notre
assemblée et la Constitution il fait de
l'irrespect une ligne de rupture dans la
société
française cet agissement pose question
comme pose question le retour de la
France dans le commandement intégré de
autant même si cette question est
aujourd'hui moins pressante en raison de
la crise économique et sociale et aussi
en raison du changement de président aux
États-Unis quoi que le nouveau président
n'it pas dit grand-chose encore à ce
sujet la première question est pourquoi
ce retour 43 ans plus tard dans une
organisation dont le but était de faire
face à un bloc dans un contexte de
guerre froide
n'aurait-il pas fallu préalablement à
tout engagement s'interroger sur la
définition d'une doctrine nouvelle d'une
stratégie nouvelle du périmètre rectifié
de l'OTAN sachant que certaines demandes
comme cellees de l'Ukraine et de la
Géorgie soulève des difficultés par
rapport à la Russie a-t-on perdu de vue
la position singulière de la France en
retrait de l'OTAN mais toujours allié
fidèle des
États-Unis rappelons-nous les semaines
qui ont précédé les débuts de la deuxème
guerre d'Irak la parole de la France qui
a cristallisé de nombreux pays autour de
sa position rappelons-nous les aveux du
président Bush sur cette période précise
au moment où il a quitter la maison
blanche dans une interview au New York
Times le 24 septembre 2007 le Président
de la République
déclarait je
conditionnerai un mouvement dans les
structures intégré par une avancée sur
l'Europe de la défense quelles sont ces
conditions ont-elles été fixées dans la
lettre adressée par le Président de la
République au secrétaire général de
l'OTAN le 20 mars dernier
s'agit-il d'une construction de la
construction d'une Europe de la défense
mais avec qui et sur quelle base on peut
pousser la question plus loin encore et
se demander si durant la présidence
française
de l'Union européenne n'aurait pu être
posé les conditions de ce mouvement et
notamment les fondement d'une politique
étrangère commune à l'Europe une
politique singulière élément d'un monde
multipolaire une politique sans
arrogance mais sans faiblesse non plus
avec tous les obscurantismes tous les
intégrisme tous les terrorismes bref on
a sans doute gâché là et pour longtemps
l'opportunité d'émanciper l'Europe sur
le plan diplomatique et militaire ce qui
maintiendra toujours l'Europe dans
l'orbite des États-Unis est-ce par souci
de mutualisation par habitude ou par
confort mais qui privera l'Europe et la
France d'une certaine autonomie et d'une
certaine liberté de jouer un rôle dans
le monde digne de son histoire qui a vu
entre autres naître la démocratie et qui
a su tirer les leçons de ces
déchirements meurtriers
pai et Don l'espoir au
monde merci mon cher
collègue la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur André
lardeo collègue
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues en réalité le débat qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui n'est pas celui de
l'ensemble politique étrangère mais
celui bien s de
notre réintégration dans le command
militaire de l'an et tout d'abord je
tiens à remercier le président du
groupe de permettre un point de vue
divergent de la pensée officielle de
pouvoir s'exprimer sur ce sujet
même si la lettre et l'esprit nos
institutions permettent la procédure
suivie il me semble qu'ilti est
préférable d'insturer un large débat
suivi d'un vote pour que chacun puisse
réellement se
prononcer au contraire on noit cette
question de la réintégration dans le
command militaire de l'an dans un
ensemble dont il était convenable de
l'extraire en raison de l'égoïsme sacré
des états les relations internationales
et les Tex qui en résulte ne sont que
des accords entre des arrières
pensées aussi serait-il bon que nous
soyons informés de
celle-ci dans le cas présent j'ai un peu
trop l'impression que c'est circuler il
y a rien à voir or le point de vue que
je vais modestement exprimer maintenant
est partagé par un certain nombre de mes
collègues de groupe UMP comme Adrien
Gouteron aussi je veux faire connaître
par souci de clarté d'honnêteté
intellectuelle mes interrogations mes
doutes ou mes réserves face au retour au
berkaaille de
l'OTAN pour cela il n'est nul besoin de
faire parler les morts en effet personne
ne peut dire ce qu'aurait fait de Gaulle
Pompidou ou mitéran alors laissons-les
tranquill il y a lieu de s'interroger
sur la pertinence de l'OTAN sur son
cadre actuel dans un monde de plus en
plus complexe où la formation d'un bloc
purement occidental n'est peut-être pas
ce qui peut contribuer à nous rapprocher
de certains pays notamment Riverin de la
Méditerranée dans ce cas certains
peuvent légitimement évoquer
l'obsolescence d'un autant de guerre
froide pour le moins il vaut mieux
réfléchir à l'avenir de l'OTAN ou à une
éventuelle redéfinition avant la
réintégration
qu'après pour l'instant je n'ai pas
entendu de réponse qui m'est convaincu à
plusieurs questions que se posent les
uns et les autres en dehors de pétition
de principe quels avantages la France
retirera-t-elle de cette décision
quelles sont les contreparties en
échange des strapontins offerts dans le
combandement quel en est le coût
politique quel en est le coût financier
on n'imagine pas que cela soit à coût
constant pour les armées sinon au
détriment de quoi quelles sont les
conséquences pour le fonctionnement de
ces mêmes forces armées aussi la
décision proposée ne peut manquer de
susciter des inquiétude même si l'on
nous dit que cela ne change rien alors
d'ailleurs dans ce cas pourquoi aller
dans ce sens dès maintenant les craintes
que j'exprime ne peuvent à mon sens
qu'exister la première crainte est celle
de l'alignement en changeant de
politique étrangère et de politique de
défense sinon la décision n'a pas de
sens nous risquons d'apparaître comme
des suiveurs des États-Unis et cela
nuira notre image d'indépendance auprès
de nombreux partenaires avec la fin de
notre liberté de ton notre capitale
diplomatique en sera
diminué malgré la règle de l'unanimité
nous risquons d'être entraînés dans des
aventures dont nous pourrons sortir
l'enlisement dans le bourbier afghan
nous ne savons plus comment sortir
devrait nous alerter nous n'avons aucun
poids sur la stratégie américaine dans
ce pays malgré les renforts que nous
avons
envoyés la seconde crainte est le
renforcement de l'hégémonie des
États-Unis certes ceuxci sont nos alliés
mais nous n'avons pas à être leur vassau
or depuis 6 an l' temp n'a pas évolué
dans ce domaine nous n'accéderons pas
plus au levier de décision que
maintenant certes la nouvelle
administration américaine paraît moins
aventuriste que la
précédente mais pour l'instant nous ne
percevons pas encore bien ce qu'elle
veut et elle n'a pas montré de signe
indiquant qu'elle était prête à partager
les responsabilités sauf à partager les
charges avant d'aller audevant des des
souhaits constants au États-Unis il
serait prudent d'attendre et voir
la troisième crainte que j'exprime est
donc qu'il ne paraît pas y avoir de
retour à laéquilibre de répartition des
responsabilités entre Américains et
Européens aucune garantie ne me semble
avoir été donnée dans ce sens bien qu'on
étant guerre partisan de l'Europe telle
qu'elle se fait ma 4è interrogation
porte sur la cohérence entre cette
décision et la volonté de construction
d'une Europe politique et une Europe de
la défense à moins que cette décision
nous amène à revoir totalement notre
politique dans ce domaine enfin est-ce
que que le nouveau format de nos armées
est compatible avec un système qui peut
nous entraîner à de nouvelles
interventions en conclusion j'espère que
la décision de réintégrer le
commandement militaire de l'OTAN n'est
pas le constat de l'affaiblissement du
pays initié par plusieurs décennies de
l'axisme budgétaire l'axisme qui est la
cause de notre délabrement financier qui
nous enlève toute marge de manœuvre et
dont l'une des traductions est
l'affaiblissement militaire je ne suis
pas certain que nous ayons encore les
moy militaire de notre politique
extérieure ce que constate notre
affaiblissement diplomatique vous l'avez
compris s'il y avait eu vote j'aurais
évidemment voté contre cette
réintégration ayant noté qu'en d'autres
temps un homme politique qui exerce
actuellement d'éminentes fonctions
soulignait que la participation de la
France replatrage de l'Alliance
atlantique s'inscrit à contretemps de
l'histoire et qu'il serait paradoxal de
rejoindre ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
hein une organisation qu'elle a quitté
la France pour échapper aux contraintes
d'un protectorat abusif et considérant
enfin que l'on sacrifie ainsi ce que je
considère comme l'intérêt supérieur du
pays merci mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président de la
Commission de la Défense Affaires
étrangères et monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
je voudrais au terme de ce débat
répondre à un certain nombre
d'interpellations auxquelles nous avons
eu
droit sais que j'ai beaucoup de
considération pour vous monsieuras et
par conséquent je j'écoute avec intérêt
tout ce que vous
dites je pourrais vous répondre tout
point de vue est faux c'est de Valérie
c'est pas de baudela mais s'agissant de
réversibilité permettez-moi de vous dire
que je ne sais pas si mes propos sont
réversibles mais la réversibilité vous
l'incarnez et je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que vous vous souviendrez qu'en
1966 je vous concède que vous n'étiez
pas encore député c'était l'année
d'après s'est déroulé un débat de
censure à l'Assemblée nationale la
censure était demandée par les partis de
gauche à l'exception du Parti communiste
qui pour des raisons que nous comprenons
fort bien de la pas voté sur quoi
portait la censure sur le fait que le
général de Gaulle voulait quitter les
structures militaires intégrées de
l'OTAN et les censeurs de talent
s'appelait comment Monsieur Mermaz il y
en a un qui s'appelait Monsieur François
mitteran hein et qui avec quelle force
quelle éloquence et quelle véhémence a
stigmatisé la décision du général de
Gaulle alors je vais vous en donner un
extrait s'agissant de cette décision
voilà ce que disait monsieur mitterran
c'est scandaleux c'est lorsqu'il s'agit
d'expliquer cette décision au français
d'affirmer que le Traité de l'Atlantique
Nord contraint la France à l'intégration
militaire en temps de paix alors que ça
n'est pas exact non la France n'a pas
perdu son autonomie d'élaboration de
conception et d'action et Monsieur Beran
ajoutait plus loin votre politique
extérieure et nationaliste elle n'est
qu'une sorte de poujadisme aux
dimensions de l'univers alors Monsieur
Mermaz lors lorsque vous voulez que nous
restions en dehors de l' temp est-ce que
vous êtes un
poujadiste qu'est-ce que disait
qu'est-ce que disait qu'est-ce que
disait monsieur Maurice fort ben ça
n'est pas beaucoup mieux monsieur
Maurice fort qui avait beaucoup de
talent nous le savons parce que nous
avons eu le privilège de l'avoir comme
collègue disait je constate après le
président plév que les engagements que
nous avons pris en temps de paix ne nous
retir en fait rien en ce qui concerne
que nos droits et ne confère à
l'état-major interallié que des
responsabilités très réduites en temps
de paix surtout dans la mesure où il ne
serait pas pleinement d'accord avec le
gouvernement français lui-même dans leur
utilisation B on ne vous le fait pas
dire ce que disait monsieur Maurice fort
était d'ailleurs rigoureusement exact
mais vous reprochiez au général de
Gaulle de faire le contraire de ce que
vous voulez faire aujourd'hui alors il
faudrait être un petit peu logique hein
et puis quant à Monsieur Gaston de fer
un homme dont la modération était
extrêmement connue voilà ce qu'il disait
à ce propos nous voici maintenant
arrivés à l'époque de
l'anti-américanisme qui cette fois
s'accompagne de toute une campagne dans
laquelle on cherche moins à expliquer et
à justifier cette politique qu'à créer
un climat de haine contre les États-Unis
en exploitant les sentiments de
xénophobie les plus méprisables je pense
que vous avez quand même oublié tout ça
monsieur merma c'est pour ça que je suis
obligé de vous le rappeler
oui deuxièmement deuxièmement vous
permettrez après ça vous pourouvez dire
tout ce que vous voudrez euh euh vous
avez parlé de la nécessité de maintenir
notre force nucléaire mais nous en
sommes tous d'accord la preuve c'est que
elle reste en dehors du commandement
intégré de l'OTAN mais enfin il me
semble me souvenir qu'il y avait 110
propositions autrefois hein où il était
question de la supprimer la force
nucléaire et je crois savoir aussi
peut-être me contredira-t-il que si
notre ami Jean-Pierre chevem nétait pas
intervenu nous avons gardé la force
nucléaire de
toute de toute façon soyez soyez
tranquillees elle sera elle sera
conservée en ce qui concerne le vote
alors là j'ai entendu plusieurs orateurs
reprocher au gouvernement de ne pas se
demander l'approbation du Sénat sur quoi
d'ailleurs sur une décision qui incombe
absolument au président de la République
car c'est la plénitude de ses fonctions
jamais le général de Gaulle l' sollicité
un vote parlementaire pour retirer les
forces françaises du commandement
intégré de l'OTAN Jacques Chirac n'a pas
davantage solliciter le le vote
parlementaire pour réintégrer les 37
comités et donc c'est une tradition de
la de la 5e
République il n'y a aucune base
constitutionnelle à un vote sur une
décision du Président de la République
pour la raison simple c'est qu'il est
irresponsable devant nous mais monsieur
chers collègues de l'opposition j'ai
connu pour ma part chers collègues de
l'opposition j'ai connu pour ma part un
grand nombre de premier ministres
socialiste je n'en connais qu'un qui a
sollicité l'approbation du Sénat sur sa
politique étrangère c'était Monsieur
Michel Rocard que nous demandait-il
d'approuver à l'époque c'était je crois
en 1988
9 il nous demandait d'appliquer la
politique de d'approuver la politique de
son gouvernement vis-à-vis de qui je
vous le demande en 1000 de la Pologne du
général jarouselski et bien je peux vous
dire que le groupe RPR le groupe RPR du
Sénat a refusé et nousous en honorons de
de de voter l'approbation à Monsieur
Rocard sur ce point précis quant à
Monsieur quant à Monsieur Jospin je ne
sache pas qu'une seule fois il est
solliciter notre approbation sur un
point de politique intérieure mais
encore moins de politique étrangère il y
a eu quand même chers collègues une
intervention de la France au Kosovo
importante nous avons bombardé Belgrade
au cours de cette intervention
avons-nous avons-nous été sollicité nous
avons demandé d'approuver quelque chose
rien du tout et de même quand vous avez
envoyé des troupes en Afghanistan
décision quand des troupes ont été
envoyé en Afghanistan sous la
cohabitation le président de la
République et le et Lionel Jospin n'ont
pas demandé qu'on approuve cette
décision alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
notre approbation n'est pas sollicitée
en aucun cas elle n'était obligatoire
voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire à titre exceptionnel et totalement
discrétionnaire de ma part je donne la
parole à Monsieur mermas avant qu'v main
puisse répondre merci monsieur le
Président je je serai très bref je vois
que le président jinuran a les mêmes
lectures que moi mais je lui demande de
rapprocher les débat de fin mars 1966 à
l'Assemblée nationale et du débat sur la
censure car François myteran a fait une
démonstration très
importante sur le fait que le général de
Gaulle ne faisait consulter par Georges
Pompidou l'Assemblée nationale que 3
mois après avoir pris la décision de
retrait très partiel de l'Alliance
atlantique et d'ailleurs François
miteran n' cessé de dire tout au long de
sa vie publique que le général de Gaulle
avait toujours bien pris garde de faire
que la France reste sous la protection
du parapluie atomique américain avant
que notre force de dissuasion soit
suffisamment forte en ce qui concerne la
force nucléaire dans les 110
propositions il n'est pas du tout
question d'abandonner la force nucléaire
là vous avez commis une erreur c'est pas
grave que vous c'est non mais c'est
normal que monsieur jusin laoran ne lise
pas autant les s% que nous enfin il faut
quand même pas être mesquin je trouve ça
normal je vous conseille j'ai presque
fini je vous concè que François mitteran
pendant des années a dénoncé la
bombinette française à propos oui parce
qu'il pensait qu'à ce
moment-là alors que les forces
nucléaires sur deux blocs commençaient à
se développer la France aurait dû
prendre la tête d'une grande croisade
internationale contre la dissémination
de l'arme nucléaire qui a commencé qui
malheureusement continue mais à partir
du moment après les communiste
d'ailleurs nous avons constaté que
l'arme nucléaire existait l'indépendance
de la France nécessitait qu'on l'arme
nucléaire j'en ai terminé pour dire que
sous la seconde cohabitation monsieur
Chirac président de la République
Monsieur Jospin Premier
ministre le Premier ministre a beaucoup
plus d'influence sur le président de la
République pour que nous n'acceptions
pas les conditions américaines qui
faisaient que si on était dans
l'Alliance atlantique d'avantage intégré
que par le passé on avait aucun pouvoir
de plus quant à l'action de Jaruzelski
faut être très nuancé jarou jarsk a
commis beaucoup d'erreurs politiqu mais
n'oubliez pas qu'il fut un moment où il
s'en e fallu de peu que bre fit donner
l'Armée rouge alors JSK n'est pas un H
polonais le H polonais Val mais les
historiens doivent savoir mesurer les
choses avec plus d'intelligence et de
finesse le
faitè polonaise ultérieurement la parole
est maintenant à monsieur Morin ministre
de la Défense vous avez la parole
monsieur le
ministresieur le président Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs un
quelques points tout d'abord la question
monsieur le Président de l'ordre du jour
et du débat puis-je tout d'abord
indiquer que nous avons que le
gouvernement a engagé sa
responsabilité sur une déclaration
relative à la politique étrangère et
nous l'avons fait en vertu de l'article
49 alinéa 1ier qui ne prévoit pas un tel
débat au Sénat c'est simplement la
lecture de la Constitution et puis je
rappel au groupe socialiste et au groupe
communiste qui a été le premier à
demander un engagement de la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur cette
question du retour dans le commandement
intégré plus globalement sur la
politique étrangère de la France c'est
Jean-Marc ho président du groupe
socialiste de l'Assemblée nationale et
quant à la date et à la fixation du
débat au Sénat elle a été effectuée à la
demande de la conférence des présidents
du Sénat qui ne souhaitait pas monsieur
le Président que le débat ait lieu un
soir et souhaitait au contraire que nous
puissions avoir le temps nécessaire pour
évoquer ces sujets et donc on ne peut
pas reprocher au gouvernement
aujourd'hui un en quelque sorte d'avoir
répondu à l'appel pressent de Jean-Marc
hraud président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale et d'autre part
d'avoir répondu à la demande de la
Conférence des présidents du Sénat qui
souhaitait que les sénateurs aient le
temps nécessaire pour é ces sujets le
deuxè le deuxè point je voudrais
évoquer monsieur chevvénement c'est
c'est tout de
même considérer que le le la décision du
général de Gaulle sur la sortie du
commandement intégré est lié à la
situation Vietnam et à son discours de
Pnom Pen c'est tout de même un raccourci
qui est me semble semble-t-il un peu
particulier quand on relit ce que vous
avez dû faire la lettre du général de
Gaulle lettre 1 adressant s'adressante à
l'OTAN et indiquant la sortie du
commandement intégré il y a trois
raisons en fait la première c'est qu'en
effet il souhaite sortir de la logique
de la guerre froide et de la logique des
blocs dans lequel nous sommes pour que
la France puisse porter dans un moment
de relatif réchauffement un autre
message que ce que le age de la logique
des des blocs et de la guerre froide le
deuxième motif indiqué expressément dans
le courrier c'est qu'il ne souhaite pas
qu'il yit des forces étrangères sur le
sol national et que des forces aériennes
puissent survoler l'espace aérien
français et la troisième raison qui est
la vraie raison profonde de tout cela
c'est qu'il est en plein débat avec les
Américains à l'époque sur l'indépendance
de notre force de dissuision et c'est
pour cela que le général de Gaulle
décide en 1966 de quitter le le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN voilà les
raisons de fond le troisième point que
je voudrais indiquer pour répondre à un
certain nombre d'orateur c'est que
honnêtement on a le sentiment que le
retour dans le commandement intégré
c'est comme si nous n'avions jamais
participer à l'Alliance atlantique nous
sommes membres fondateurs de l'Alliance
atlantique nous sommes tenus par les
engagements de l'article 5 de l'Alliance
atlantique nous avons signé le traité de
Washington en
1949 nous avons depuis le milieu des
années 90 fait un chemin
considérable nous avons participé à tous
les engagements militaires de l'Alliance
atlantique même du temps de François
mitteran avec la Bosnie nous avons
participé nous avons donné notre accord
pour que le chef d'état-major des armées
participe au comité militaire de
l'Alliance à partir de
1995 nous sommes nous participons aux
forces de réserve stratégique de
l'Alliance depuis 2001 c'est-à-dire que
chaque fois que nous sommes appelés aux
générations de forces des forces
réserves stratégiqu de l'Alliance nous y
participons et nous sommes le meilleur
élève de l'Alliance atlantique quels que
soient les majorités nous participons
aux forces à la force de réaction rapide
de l'Alliance Atlantique depuis 2003
depuis sa création tout cela bien
entendu sans qu'il n'y ait à aucun
moment le moindre débat parlementaire le
moindre expression politique d'un
gouvernement que le gouvernement soit de
gauche du tempsonel Jospin ou qu'il soit
de droite après 2001 enfin nous
commandons des opérations de l'Alliance
nous avons commandé euh en Afghanistan
avec le général pi en 2003 ou en 2004 de
mémoire et nous avons commandé à deux
reprises au Kosovo et donc nous avons eu
depuis 15 ans une attitude qui nous a
amené à réintégrer 38 des 40 comités et
sous-comité de l'Alliance atlantique et
qui nous a amené selon un une jolie
formule à insérer plus d'une une
centaine d'officiers dans l'ensemble des
états-majors de l'Alliance nous avons
fait à B bruit un retour presque entier
dans le commandement intégré de
l'Alliance mais sans à aucun moment être
en mesure d'être assez fort assez
présent pour participer à quelque chose
qui pour le ministre de la Défense que
je suis et celui que vous avez été me
semble naturel c'est que pour participer
à l'élaboration des opérations à la
réflexion sur les opérations aux
décisions stratégique sur tel ou tel
engagement militaire et bien moi je
préfère que nos hommes qui sont engagés
sur le terrain avec l'Alliance
atlantique dans toutes les opérations
depuis 1995 sacheent que dans
l'élaboration des missions dans les
conditions d'organisation des missions
et bien il y ait aussi des officiers et
des militaires français qui soient en
mesure de participer à la réflexion au
sein de l'Alliance atlantique et dans
les états-majur on accepte que des
hommes français que des soldats français
soient engagés dans toute toutes les
opérations militaires de l'Alliance et
en revanche on n'accepterait pas que
nous participions à la réflexion et à la
détermination des missions auquel nous
sommes engagés sur le terrain parfois au
risque de la vie de nos soldats comme
nous le voyons régulièrement en
Afghanistan reconnaissez là qu'il y a au
moins au minimum une contradiction
majeure qu'il faut au moins avoir le
courage de dire deuxème
chose que je voudrais indiquer l'OT temp
n'est pas celle l'OT temp d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas l'OT temp d'hier l'OTAN de
1966 c'est une autant où même si
François mitteran a raison c'est une
aant où nous sommes dans un système
quasi automatique où comme vous le savez
nous étions nous déterminés ou
prédéterminés à envahir la
Tchécoslovaquie et la RDA aujourd'hui
l'Alliance atlantique est un système en
quelque sorte à la carte où on décide ou
non de participer à une opération où on
décide d'y envoyer les troupes que nous
souhaitons y envoyer et où nous
continuons en permanence à être sous une
double commande en Afghanistan on en a
d'ailleurs une preuve et nous le
regrettons régulièrement en Afghanistan
ces fameux caveat ces fameuses réserves
opérationnelles c'est bien la preuve
qu'en permanence les forces militaires
de l'Alliance engagé en Afghanistan
elles sont certes sous le
commandement du système au temps mais
elles restent en même temps sous le
commandement national sous un contrôle
qui reste un contrôle national à tout
moment preuve s'il en est dans toutes
les opération en permanence les pays
indiquent dans quelles conditions leurs
forces peuvent être engagées et dans
quelles conditions les forces peuvent
éventuellement se retirer de telle ou
telle mission nous le vivons
malheureusement de façon trop trop trop
prignante en Afghanistan troisème
élément que je voudrais indiquer sur
l'Europe de la défense et l'Alliance
atlantique
moi je l'ai découvert très sincèrement
je l'ai découvert en devenant en
accédant à ses responsabilités j'ai
découvert quelque chose que je ne
mesurais pas c'est que pour les
Européens leur système de sécurité
collective c'est l'alliance atlantique
et que la vision que certains d'entre
nous moi le premier porte c'est-à-dire
la construction politique d'une Europe
que vous ne portez pas vous monsieur
chauenement mais la construction
politique de l'Europe c'est une vision
qui n'est pas partagée par la totalité
des membres et de toute façon quoi qu'il
arrive ce que les européens souhaitent
c'est resté dans un système qui leur
assure la paix depuis près de 60 ans 59
ans et quelques mois c'est l'alliance
atlantique et d'ailleurs s'il fallait en
avoir la preuve c'est l'article 42 du
traité de Lisbonne et d'ailleurs le
traité de Lisbonne qui affirme et
affiche la politique européenne de
sécurité et défense rappelle dans son
alienéa 7 quelque chose extrêmement
clair les engagements et la coopération
dans ce domaine c'est-à-dire en matière
de politique européenne de sécurité et
de défense demeure conforme aux
engagements souscrits au sein de
l'Organisation du Traité de l'Atlantique
Nord qui reste pour les États qui en
sont membres le fondement de leur
défense collective et l'instance de sa
mise en œuvre et donc pour les Européens
dont 21 membres sur 26 sont membres
aussi de l'Alliance atlantique le
système de sécurité collective majeur
c'est l'alliance atlantique et pour les
Européens il y avait dans la volonté
française de pousser l'Europe de la
défense un doute un soupçon je crois je
sais plus qui a employé le mot de
soupçon le soupçon que nous poussions
l'Europe de la défense dans la
perspective éventuelle d'affaiblir
l'Alliance atlantique et bien tant que
nous étions dans cette démarche l'Europe
de la défense ne pouvait pas progresser
autant que nous le souhaitions et
contraire ement à ce que vous indiquez
durant la présidence française l'Europe
de la défense a connu un véritable élan
mais l'élan il ne s'est pas fait sur des
institutions il s'est pas fait sur des
organisations il s'est pas fait sur des
mots sur des mots qui Infiné sont
souvent V de sens souvent V de concret
et de pragmatique et ce que nous
reprochaient les Européens c'est en
revanche de ne jamais proposer des
choses concrètes pragmatiques qui nous
permettaient d'avancer et ça a été la
démarche française de faire dans le
concret et de faire dans le pragmatique
et qu'avons-nous fait des capacités
militaires nouvelles je ve dire le fait
d'avoir lancé un programme comme le
programme Musis Xavier Pinta en a parlé
programme d'observation satellitaire qui
est majeur pour l'Europe capacité pour
les Européens décision des Européens de
partager ces informations au au sein du
centre d'imagerie européen permettant
aux Européens d'analyser les crises de
pouvoir les prévenir de pouvoir les les
anticiper de pouvoir avoir une
connaissance propre leur permettant
d'avoir une décision autonome et
indépendante ça a été fait durant la
présidence française quand on parle du
programme de rénovation des hélicoptères
des pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
pour que nous puissions développer une
capacité
etliipter supplémentaire et
complémentaire en Europe c'est durant la
présidence française quand on parle de
du groupe aéronaval européen c'est
durant la présidence française et quand
on par parle enfin de la flotte
européenne de transport tactique qui
permettra aux Européens de pouvoir
mutualiser des moyens de transport
tactique ça a été fait durant la
présidence française et quand on parle
par exemple de la création d'un réseau
de surveillance maritime européen qui
permettra de la mer Baltique à la mer
Méditerranée d'avoir des Européens qui
auront partageront le même réseau de
surveillance qui pourront mettre des
moyens ensemble pour répondre à telle ou
telle crise ça a été aussi lancé durant
la présidence française et je pourrais
continuer longtemps et si ça pu si cela
a pu être fait c'est en effet parce que
nous avions levé le doute qu'avaient les
Européens sur notre volonté en quelque
sorte d'affaiblir l'Alliance atlantique
à travers la construction de la défense
européenne et le meilleur message
politique c'est l'opération
Atalante opération Atalante plus grosse
opération militaire européenne première
opération navale d'envergure et cette
opération navale d'envergure elle s'est
menée sur une proposition
franco-espagnole et elle s'est mené de
telle façon que les Européens ont été
les leaders du monde sur cette question
c'est c'est nous qui avons porté ce
projet-là et c'est grâce à l'initiative
européenne que l'Alliance atlantique est
venue à nos côtés que les chinois sont
venus à nos côté que les Russes sont
venus à nos côté que même les Japonais
pour la première fois depuis 1900 5 ont
décidé de participer à cette opération
et d'engager des forces en dehors de
leur territoire national et bien c'est
parce que les Européens ont été ont
compris le message de la France et
tel le meilleur exemple quoi tout du
moins la plus belle expression de de
cette compréhension là c'est que les
Britanniques ont acceptter le
commandement de cette opération et qu'en
plus le centre de commandement est aussi
à Norfolk à Northwood pardon
c'est-à-dire au Royaume-Uni et donc on
voit bien qu'à travers l'expression
française de la complémentarité de la
construction de la défense européenne et
de l'Alliance atlantique et bien on fait
progresser l'Europe de la défense je ne
sais plus qui a parler de l'Agence
européenne de défense ah oui elle a été
créée depuis 2004 l'Agence européenne de
défense elle existe mais depuis 2004
elle n'avait rien à faire on trouvait
pas le moyen de pouvoir mener un ou deux
programmes de recherche sérieux et bien
durant la présidence française l'Agence
européenne de défense a enfin des
programmes de recherche qui permettront
de développer progressivement une base
industrielle et technologique européenne
et par ailleurs tout de même j'ai en
terme puis-je au moins sourire quand
j'entends un certain nombre de sénateurs
de cesban défendre la défense européenne
alors qu'ils se sont opposés violemment
à la fois au Traité constitutionnel et
ensuite au traité de Lisbonne
honnêtement il y a
il y a dans cette histoire un peu un peu
de ça mériterait un peu de un peu de
recul tout du moins sur la question
oui bien sûr sur la politique étrangère
l'indépendance et je parle sous le
contrôle de Bernard couchner qui peut
penser un seul instant que
l'indépendance notre politique étrangère
est vécue par le monde par le monde
entier par le seul fait de réintégrer de
retourner dans quelques étatsmajurs de
l'OTAN notre politique étrangère la voix
de la France elle ne dépend pas de
l'intégration dans un 39e comité et dans
des étatsmajurs elle dépend d'une seule
chose c'est notre capacité à porter un
message c'est notre squelette c'est
notre colonne vertébrale et c'est notre
capacité apporter un message indépendant
autonome alliés des États-Unis mais
libre et debout et capable de pouvoir
porter un message qui est éventuellement
est différent de celui des États-Unis
c'est ça la la la capacité de porter la
voix de la France et qui peut penser un
seul instant que dans le monde les
Français et la France ne soient pas vécu
comme appartenant à la famille des
démocraties occidentales pour le monde
entier nous sommes dans la famille des
démocraties occidentales avec une voix
capable de porter un autre message que
celui des Américains car capable de
s'opposer capable d'avoir une colonne
vertébrale en fonction des sujets voilà
sujet dernier point que je voudrais
évoquer on a parlé sur de nombreux bans
de l'évolution de l'OTAN en effet c'est
un vrai sujet l'évolution de l'Alliance
atlantique et ce sera un des rendez-vous
et un des points majeur du sommet de
Strasbourg kel mais je voudrais vous
poser cette question comment peut
peut-on participer à la rénovation du
concept stratégique à la réflexion sur
les missions d'alliance Atlantique vrai
sujet vous avez raison d'évoquer comment
peut-on évoquer la la question de
l'élargissement de l'Alliance et des
frontières de l'Alliance si je puis
limiter ça en ces mots comment peut-on
évoquer la réforme des structures de
l'Alliance vrai sujet comme la évoquer
un certain nombre d'entre vous comment
peut-on parler peser sur ces questions
être en dehors des structures si on veut
pouvoir peser et compter au sein de
l'Alliance atlantique si nous voulons
que que les européens soient mieux pris
en compte et plus pris en compte au sein
de l'Alliance atlantique et bien il faut
y participer on ne peut pas être dehors
et penser un seul instant que nous
serons en mesure de peser sur la
rénovation du concept stratégique et sur
l'évolution d'alliance Atlantique enfin
un dernier mot oui en effet dans la
réflexion de l'Alliance il doit y avoir
aussi une réflexion sur notre relation
avec la Russie il est temps en effet que
nous soyons en mesure de créer un
partenariat de confiance et une zone de
paix et de sécurité avec les Russes ce
qui imposera à l'alliance d'avoir une
démarche qui soit une démarche beaucoup
plus de confiance et de transparence et
de dialogue avec les Russes et c'est
cela que les Américains ont décidé
d'engager d'ailleurs à travers les
premières déclarations du président
Obama et c'est cela que l'alliance doit
construire avec les Russes une nouvelle
relation de confiance pour créer une
zone de sécurité et de paix en Europe et
j'observe d'ailleurs que sur la question
du déploiement de la défense antimissile
le président Obama a déjà fait largement
marche arrière en posant un certain
nombre de questions donc mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le retour dans
le commandement intégré de l'Alliance
atlantique c'est moi j'en suis convaincu
et et nous en sommes tous convaincus
c'est le meilleur moyen de faire avancer
la défense européenne c'est le meilleur
moyen pour que les européen soit en
mesure un jour de pouvoir prendre en
main leur sécurité parce que on quittera
cette espèce de soupçon permanent qui
pouvait exister entre la défense de la
construction européenne et par ailleurs
l'Alliance atlantique je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
ministre je donne je donne
acte de la déclaration du gouvernement
je voudrais remercier le président de la
Commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées l'ensemble
des sénateurs pour leur participation à
ce débat qui a été fort intéressant je
vous remercie mes chers collègues vous
venez de suivre le débat sur la
réintégration de la France dans l'OTAN
vous pourrez revoir cette séance sur
notre site internet
www.publiksenat.fr merci de votre
attention très bonne soirée sur notre
antenne